[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen people of
the internet
welcome back to another retro rack and
tour live
let's see how many roads does this make
now guys we've got quite a nice little
stretch going here
welcome welcome everybody gather round
gather round
let's see we have done one two three
four this is our fifth straight tuesday
so every tuesday in august we did a live
stream guys to talk hogwarts legacy so
why stop now right why stop now just
when the news
seems to be flowing like crazy at the
moment
for better or worse right it's been all
kinds of news lately good news bad news
bizarre news
everything in between
[Music]
hello
welcome back guys welcome back
how's everybody doing tonight
i know we were a little bit later
getting started tonight but
those of you who follow the channel
regularly know you know about the uh the
family obligations so
any savior
thank you so much for the two dollar
super chat slytherin
where are you at
not here sorry sorry oni not here
oh man
yeah i've been shooting for 8 p.m
that's 8 p.m eastern my time and that's
like we try to have the kids in bed by
eight on the school night
but that just makes it really tough for
me to like get them in bed and then rush
straight over
for the uh for the live stream so i said
let me push it back to 8 30. so this
time we had a nice we started the 10
minute countdown at 8 20
leading in nicely here so oni thank you
so much for the support thank you for
that super chat
retro guy gaming what's up we got jason
ingram in the house jason welcome back i
see ben here nico was here as well ryan
last name make sure i get a shout out
for all the members here guys
we got nico we got jason i saw ryan as
well
i saw dylan there right when we first
got started dylan welcome we got lily
potter here tonight logan is back puppet
master is here jai
lily potter ladies and gentlemen lily
potter in our presence last week we had
mrs weasley here
we had um
we're trying to think i think we had
was it rookwood or ran rock we had one
of them
we got victor here we got rebecca here
joseph live dance laugh music love
ct707
yo retro guy gaming dude thank you so
much for becoming a channel member you
just unlocked access to those uh slick
new
emotes we've got four of them but i have
a couple more slots open and i think it
was nico who reminded me right before we
started
i hey you know what i'm gonna write it
down
i keep a little uh
just a little piece of paper and a pen
right by my desk just for that reason
so i'm gonna write it down right now
because i i basically have all the
assets already it's this it's this
merlin right here this order of merlin
so i think for the e mode it might be
best just to like have the head but i'll
play around with it
so i'm gonna write it down right now
merlin
emoji
merlin emoji merlin emo whatever i'll
know what it means
malicious melons
ligma is it what no no way
i don't believe it we got fred here we
fred
fred and george were here last time too
fred george welcome back
moses welcome dev welcome
is that a hogwarts legacy dev by chance
just curious
movies tv welcome hey i just saw movies
tv subscribed right before uh right
before i came on thank you so much for
subscribing to the channel
jay rossi here in the house cam is in
the house welcome
sawyer yes i thought we're gonna talk
about it here we're gonna talk about it
here tonight
so much happens like
it used to be
following this game guys
it was like we were wandering in the
desert just just
dying of thirst for any little morsel of
information
but now
not that i'm complaining but now we've
had some just like crazy news just back
to back to back to back to back
pre-order pandemonium as i like to call
it because it's been uh pretty crazy so
we're gonna check in on pre-orders
tonight we're gonna see what the status
is at several different retailers
if you didn't catch my tweet today
amazon did go live with the deluxe
edition
and i also heard that they went live
briefly with the collectors i can't
confirm that
as soon as i saw that
someone's saying that the collectors was
up i looked and it was already it was
not showing it so i don't know if that
part was accurate or not but we're going
to take a look at uh walmart amazon
target best buy
see what the status is on all of those
because as far as i know
it's been for the collector's edition
it's still only been posted
for about a one hour window on gamestop
and then a very
tiny tiny window
for best buy for the pc version
[Music]
legacy got you into harry potter nice
that's pretty cool
dude i'm so ready for back to hogwarts i
can't wait
yeah we're definitely going to talk
about the uh
dialogue options for sure for sure
[Music]
uh midernator
i
i think it's just one year you're right
it's not been confirmed anywhere
i think it's just one year and i think
they'll set it up for a trilogy if they
if the game does well enough and is
received well enough i think they're
setting up for a possible trilogy
because then it'd be like year five six
and seven you know
hello
how are you
welcome to gryffindor only savior also
becoming a member
dude thank you so much for the support
chelsea with a subscription chelsea
thank you so much for subscribing to the
channel
and uh
oni unlocked the slick new emotes right
there
brandon gower brandon thank you so much
for subbing to the channel as well
but yeah i mean
because of like
it's crazy how much has happened in the
span of a week right
because
let's see i gotta go back and look
through my videos here
so we did this was four days ago right
here this video here this one was six
days ago
and then this was my so last week last
tuesday is when we got the
trailer and then after that point
is when everything went crazy
everything everything went crazy after
the trailer
so just to kind of walk you guys through
i mean most of you probably know already
but if not we'll just do it
tell it very quickly
new shirt idea i survived the hogwarts
legacy pre-order debacle
oh man
well pre-orders in general are kind of a
touchy subject right because no some
people are just like
never pre-order and i get it i do i
really get it
but for me i'm pre-during hogwarts
legacy simply because
this game could could launch with
reviews of a a two out of ten
and i'm gonna play it
and i wanna play it when it launches
that's pretty much it
that is pretty much it i'm gonna play it
no matter what
lower the music a bit yeah we can lower
just a bit here
oh wait actually i think i probably
don't want to lower it right here let me
try
try to lower it right here
oh yeah we had it on max by the way if
you guys are curious this is a
celtic medieval tavern music no
copyright relaxation harmony
volume three
[Music]
so that's what we're listening to here
tonight gotta stick with the no
copyright but yeah this is the one we've
we've been listening to for a while
everybody seems to like it so we uh
we're sticking with it it's four hours
long we haven't had a stream go four
hours yet so
but yeah i mean just in the span of a
week
it's been ridiculous how much has
happened
yeah the early access
i'm honestly not a fan of the early
access but clearly is like a marketing
tactic
it works but i'm just not a fan of it
you know not a fan of it
[Music]
you have a code for the devs from the
devs uh that'd be awesome
that would be awesome
haven't heard anything
they probably do that you know closer to
time but
yeah so to give you guys my pre-order
story
so i had to work i was at work that day
when they went live and also
it's been like a thing with me and work
meetings lately everything going on with
hogwarts legacy and i've been in a
meeting at that exact time
so i had a meeting for i'm on eastern
time so 11 a.m eastern is when they were
saying the pre-orders were gonna go live
and honestly guys i've been so torn
about this collector's edition
i've been so torn because personally
[Music]
i'm disappointed with it
but i've
and i think most people are i think it's
way overpriced
just ridiculously overpriced for what
you get there could have been something
really special
but
at the same time as someone covering
this game
you know i feel like it's something that
i mean i could easily
do a giveaway if i don't want it after
the fact but i feel like i need to cover
it i need to show you guys
what it's like in person because
chandler would you know he did the
unboxing but as someone who's working
with hogwarts legacy he's not going to
be
at liberty to discuss the intricate
details right of like does this feel
very well made or does this feel cheap
and
how long how long do i think this little
floating uh
wand will let last you know
[Music]
tyler oh yeah definitely i keep i keep
track of the chat
dude we got jenny we do we almost have
the whole
weasley family here
george weasley here oh that's that's
amore amore poet right
i heard expect a go pronounce your name
and i was like oh that's right
i totally forgot
mori poet i'm gonna try to remember that
yeah collector's edition so i i did go
ahead and pre-order one i did manage to
get one in at gamestop i don't know how
so i was at work i was in that meeting
uh we had a meeting start right at 11
and then i was ki like i have twitter
open too because part of my job is doing
twitter and things like that for my
workplace
and
so i was kind of keeping track of things
and seeing oh it's
it's not really going live like they
said and so then when i got done with
that meeting
i just kept kind of refreshing the
gamestop page finally got a collector's
edition pre-order to go in for the uh
ps5 version
but think about pre-orders guys is
i'm pretty sure most all retailers i
don't want to say every retailer because
there might be one out there that i have
no idea about but most of them i mean
you can you can get a refund you can
cancel your pre-order
so that's why i went ahead and
pre-ordered it and then i also
pre-ordered a deluxe from best buy as
well
and as far as i know i don't think that
um i don't think expecto go has ever
gotten his pre-order in unfortunately aj
draws what's up dude
aj welcome aj draws everybody
responsible for my twitter
profile picture right here
let me let me go home right here
right there aj draws everybody so this
is me right here supposed to be me i
think it looks pretty close
more hair a little more hair than i have
actually but hey i'll take it
um but aj did a phenomenal piece of art
with uh
some of their favorite hogwarts legacy
or really harry potter creators
which was an incredible gesture and so
i'm like i just have to i have to make
this my twitter profile pic
you're in a meeting also and also got
the collector's edition in for the ps5
dylan says
oh that's crazy
hi one two three
jake
jake right
is it jake
it's jake from state farm
waiting for collectors on pc yeah so the
collectors on pc has been probably the
most bizarre one you're a wizard harry
eclipse
welcome thank you for subscribing to the
channel
weasley is our king might get a ps5 just
for this game artemis says wizard
ghetto also subscribing to the channel
thank you so much
i want to order the hard copy deluxe
eventually yeah i you're a wizard i'm a
big fan of hard copies as well
bartolome
thank you so much for subscribing
nico got a pre-order collector's edition
on pc on gamestop canada okay no hassle
at all thought i did something wrong it
seemed like everybody was having a hard
time
yeah it's uh
it's kind of different based on
territories it seems like
i'm gonna turn this down just a wee bit
more or it might just
it's kind of loud in my ear but
hopefully that's good for you guys
[Music]
if it's too loud just let me know we can
we can adjust it again
that's a great question jake
i've been wondering the same thing i
don't know if it's a typo
or what i mean i don't think it is
because avalanche put it actually in the
trailer so jake was asking there guys
why does the xbox hard copy say requires
xbox live yeah so let's get into it here
so this is the latest i'm gonna pull up
amazon
so amazon finally went live today with
the deluxe editions
so you can see here they they have the
switch deluxe edition right here
nice look at the box start there on the
switch still no release date for switch
then you go over to ps4
same deal here
playstation 5.
notice this top left area of the box by
the way
any of you who follow me on twitter you
already know what i'm going to say but
this is a very uh just kind of strange
one it's got the thestrals up there in
the top right
then here here's what they're talking
about xbox
right there requires internet
i have no idea
i have no idea i don't know what it's
about i don't know why they're having
that on there but then look at this
this one has a dragon on it
it has a dragon and at first i thought
you know what i was thinking maybe this
is just like a retailer error
but if you go back and watch the end of
that most recent trailer whenever they
pop the deluxe editions up on screen the
boxes are different
the boxes are different it's a good
volume nice thank you guys
probably just for registration with
other wb games yeah i i
i don't think it's anything major it is
just kind of weird that it's like
requires internet
because i know i i'm pretty sure
chandler said that no
extra connection at all was required
because there was something that
appeared on steam for a while that
talked about linking it to your
wizarding world account
and and wb account so everybody was
thinking um
actually people were kind of excited
about that we'll talk we'll talk about
that here here in a second
but yeah then if you go over to series x
same thing now let's look at collector's
edition so collector's edition so it's
interesting because here it says
temporarily out of stock
this is for xbox series x
xbox one same thing temporarily out of
stock
playstation five oh they've actually
updated this temporarily out of stock
temporarily out of stock so they all say
temporarily out of stock now
so i heard they went live briefly i
haven't seen a screenshot yet of anybody
who got an order in
on amazon for the collectors
um but yeah so that's that's where we're
at on amazon i also pulled up target
here
hogwarts legacy deluxe
this whole rollout has been very strange
it's been very strange because at first
they said
11 a.m eastern time
last what was it thursday or whatever
friday i don't i don't remember the
exact day but whatever they said
and then so the time came and it's like
um where are the orders and then later
they say oh it's actually going to be
this rolling it's going to be this
rolling
basis so retailer is going to be coming
online seemingly at random which is what
we've seen happening so it looks like
target doesn't even have the deluxe up
yet
because i think that's what i yeah
that's exactly what i searched right yep
nothing all right so let's take them off
the list this is best buy which by the
way
if you want to pre-order um again i'm
not here to tell you whether you should
pre-order or not i think you should
definitely think
twice about pre-ordering
um but if you want to if you're like me
and you know you're playing this game no
matter what then it's up to you so
if you want to support the channel um
you can i tweeted out some amazon
affiliate links you can pre-order
through those um if you want to save
yourself 10 bucks
best buy is doing um on every
edition of the game so you see this free
10 gift card with purchase it is not
just for the collectors it is also even
on the standard so even if you're going
with the standard version here free 10
gift card with purchase i'm pretty sure
it's an e gift card but um yeah so you
can you can get ten dollars back target
if you're a red card member you get like
five percent back so i'll try and keep
everybody aware of any of the deals
going on
nightly nerd night leaner welcome
feathers mcgraw in the house as well
feathers welcome ebay has so many
collector distances oh man is that us
a mori poet i was underwhelmed with a
collector's edition too but still wanted
it couldn't afford it financially ah
state of play was amazing and since then
less exciting
wonder if we can set accidental fires
oh in the game
well
there's a uh there's a screenshot we
need to talk about when it comes to that
uh beef supreme steam pre-orders are up
as well
they are up as well
and um
so yeah this is best buy status when it
comes to collectors everything says
coming soon
whether that's correct or not
i don't know but it doesn't say sold out
it says coming soon there's no way
they're already out of collector's
editions there's just no way like they
didn't allot all of them to gamestop
you're a wizard and they sold out
pretty quick harrison thank you so much
for subbing to the channel
but let's uh i'll show you guys here
what it's talking about on the
so best buy does have the deluxe as well
which
i thought you could get to it there we
go from this page
right there so best buy does indeed have
the deluxe you're a wizard harry
scott taylor scott thank you for subbing
to the channel
yeah so
lily pre-orders are up for the switch
navajo
or navajo ninja
thank you so much for subbing to the
channel
getting digital deluxe yeah i mean if
you're going digital they're not gonna
run out of those and they're honestly
guys they're not gonna run out of the
deluxe either so
you can wait
really the only one that you need to act
quickly like if you really wanted it was
collectors but most people were
disappointed with that anyway
so
i mean it was so
everything went so crazy that they even
had to put out
an official statement from hogwarts
legacy which i thought i had it pulled
up here but i don't think i did let me
scroll up here
so here's what they said most of you
probably already seen this but
it's this little tweet thread right here
so i mean clearly the collec if you
really did want a collector's edition it
seems like they're not they're not sold
out so they say right here collectors
editions are going live with our
retailers on a rolling basis
[Music]
whatever that means right for clarity
pre-order of the ps4 and ps5 edition
standard deluxe digital deluxe and
collectors will come with a felix
felicis potion recipe
that also got a lot of people riled up
right there all playstation editions
will come with the exclusive quest no
pre-order is required to obtain it
more information around sony exclusives
is coming soon i wonder when that could
be
right i wonder when that could be
yeah digital deluxe i mean digital the
deluxe is not priced i think it's priced
very
reasonably
um it's only 10 extra dollars
but probably the best deal of them all i
think is the steam
i think it's the steam digital deluxe
because it's ten dollars cheaper
than all the next-gen stuff for the
digital looks
crazy
exclusive quests no unfortunately keelan
exclusive means exclusive so
it's only on uh playstation platforms
now here's the thing i'll say about
because i know there's a lot of new
people who
i'm not saying this about you could be
you could be other people that aren't as
familiar with the video game industry
and how these sort of um
exclusive editions work
sometimes things are what they call
timed exclusives
this is what happened with the original
destiny so you remember the original
destiny had a
an agreement with playstation to where i
think it was like a one-year exclusivity
so amir welcome amir thank you for
stopping by
but all of that stuff eventually came to
xbox now i'm not saying that's what's
happening here because we just have no
idea
and
you know it it doesn't playstation
obviously if that is the case and it is
timed they want that to stay
under wraps as long as possible
avalanche is contractually obligated
whatever that agreement says
whatever that agreement says is what
avalanche and wb have to state you know
they have to stay true to whatever that
agreement with
sony says
um but
you can you can believe people will be
asking and
i would be
i hate to say either way
in term like i hate to say
definitively one way or another because
i don't want to get people's hopes up
but i i wouldn't be surprised let me put
it that way i wouldn't be surprised if
it eventually did come to xbox
maybe like a year a year down the road
wouldn't be surprised
uh lily you keep asking about the switch
i don't know what what you mean about
the switch
we don't really know much about the
switch yet
pre-orders are up for it nobody's seen
it
playable nobody's seen what it would
look like at all
and we also do not have a date for the
switch yet so
that's really that's really all there is
to say about the switch unfortunately
um but yeah so walmart i did find uh
walmart has the deluxe edition up now as
well
and then let's see there was one more we
already had best buy here so we already
talked about best buy we already talked
about amazon so yeah we talked about all
of them except let's go to the official
hogwarts legacy website i want to see
what they what they're saying here
so this is the little uh they put up
this pre-order now button this is still
here
and then you can go and you can choose
your edition
and then they have all the platforms
here so that i mean they
this clearly shows you guys i mean
they're trying to do what they can to
keep this updated but this is not real
time because we just looked at the
deluxe is already on
walmart it's already on amazon it's
already on best buy and they don't have
any of those listed
they don't have any of those listed
so i would not rely on this one this
website here as your source for the most
up-to-date information
stick to stick to twitter stick to you
know checking in on the retailers
yourself this is only if by the way this
is only if you're somebody who really
wants the uh the collectors this one
right here
because the others
you're not gonna have to worry about
these these are these are gonna be
there's gonna be plenty of these out
there
and i mean if worse comes to worse on
either one of these you can always get
the digital you know
um but yeah really this is the only one
that there needs to be any concern about
levi thank you for subbing in the
channel
dude we have the nose of sauron in here
too no way
oh man
oh jake's birthday's coming up
let's see did i miss
that i missed it
will old gen consoles get a digital
deluxe separate from the next gen
not really sure what you mean
um i mean yes like there there is a ps4
digital deluxe version yes
however it also includes a free upgrade
to the ps5 version
same for xbox one version
there is a digital deluxe version of
xbox one that includes a free upgrade to
the xbox series x version yeah
and then somebody was asking i saw about
the dialogue so yeah we can go ahead and
talk about that because this one's
pretty brief so this was a new tweet
that hogwarts legacy shared today we've
gotten used to them doing updates on
thursdays
this thursday's back to hogwarts day so
we're gonna get a big one then gonna get
a big one there excuse me yo expecto go
how are you
welcome to griffin what is up james
welcome dude thank you so much for
becoming a channel member there
very much appreciate it guys shout out
to expecto golf
most of you here have probably already
seen his videos but if you haven't
check him out on another
hogwarts legacy youtuber
one of my favorites to go and watch i
say that
truthfully every expect to go video pops
up
i gotta watch it immediately he just put
up a new one today about um
hogwarts and
the fact that well i shouldn't say the
fact the theory he has a theory i think
it's a pretty good theory
that um hogwarts is somehow
the reason for our magic suddenly
appearing
and that it is almost in a way calling
us the hogwarts very interesting video
don't want to give it all away so you
guys go go check it out it's your boy
james over at expecto go that's right
expect to go in the house do pre-orders
usually last yes i've been at getting
asked that a lot too yeah so pre-orders
guys i mean you could pre-order all the
way up i'm pretty sure on digital you
could pre-order until like
the minute before something goes live
um and then at retailers i mean
literally until the day of so
lurking and hanging out smash the like
button
hey thank you so much james
almost at 30k
nice mrs weasley
nice that's awesome yeah we hit we hit
27k a couple streams ago
yeah james is great music is so amazing
you like the music jack yeah it's pretty
good it's this uh non-copyright celtic
medieval tavr music if any of you are
interested there's the
there's the creator right there or the
channel where it's uploaded relaxation
harmony
so
what was that somebody asked me oh yeah
before james uh before james uh became a
member we were talking about the new
dialogue so
honestly like i'm almost more intrigued
by this uh tweet that accompanied it
accompanied it's hard to say
then i am the actual content of the
video
so listen to this tweet in a forgotten
passage below
hogwarts
in a forgotten passage below hogwarts
you guys a choice must be made
and then it's showing a scene from that
recent trailer a scene that i it's funny
i put out a video today as well and in
that video i talked about how you could
tell they they cut the dialogue portion
of that video
like it was like they were getting ready
to show the choice
and then i guess for time constraints or
whatever you could you could clearly
tell where that part was cut
so
this
is what we did not see this right here
so unfortunately there's no sound but
this is our first look guys at what
the dialogue selection will look like in
hogwarts legacy so the way that
sebastian phrases the question
it sounded like we would have two
options
but instead it looks like there's going
to be three options in this case
so if you haven't seen the trailer or
just to refresh this happens right when
um sebastian and our main character who
in this case is the hufflepuff here
they get to the door
in this
i hate to call it a chamber but dungeon
maybe
below
hogwarts forgotten passage below
hogwarts
and sebastian says hold on i don't want
to get it wrong
basically i'll i'll summarize i don't
remember the exact wording but it's um i
can cast crucio on you or i can teach it
to you
so basically sebastian will teach us
crucio
or he will cast it on us
and then you can kind of see the camera
shift as they go to the point of okay
now you have to decide
this is an optional quest by the way
something else that chandler confirmed
and then here are the options that we
get
very well i don't want to learn the
cruciatus curse
i want to learn the cruciatus curse but
you must cast it on me
and then the final one teach me the
cruciatus curse and i'll cast it on you
so we've got our clear evil option right
here
then we have our kind of uh gray option
maybe and then this is like no i don't
want any part of the dark arts right
here
this one in the middle is the one that
intrigues me the most
it really is
because
if you
take take what we just saw there
and then we're also going to go to the
faq here because they also updated the
faq section
and this one right here immediately
jumped out to me does howard 60 have a
morality system
hogwarts legacy does not have a morality
system but players will encounter
various quests and storylines that will
influence the witch or wizard they
choose to become now unfortunately even
though we have this and even though we
have the dialogue options right here
i still don't think we have the answer
to the most important question
which is what expecto go's been asking
it's what i've been asking it's what
other hogwarts legacy fans have been
asking
what are the consequences
what are the consequences
that's the big question
because
in this in this specific scenario right
here
this second option is so interesting
because this is is like your option of
like i i want to learn this this curse
because i may use it at some point
if you say very well i don't want to
learn then that is like completely
locking you out of it like i don't think
you'll ever get another opportunity to
to learn it in the game maybe it will i
don't know but but to me that's like
i could see that actually having impact
you know like you will not be able to
use this curse the rest of the game if
you if you're gonna be
adamant and say no i don't want any part
of the dark arts
if you say i want to learn it but you
must cast it on me
[Music]
that was so interesting because it's
almost like a way for you to learn the
curse
but still maintain your
goodness or whatever
but
then you have the fact that they say
there is no morality system so it's like
if there's nothing tracking it
then what are the what is the impact
what are the repercussions
i say that word wrong in my video today
i don't know why i always want to say
pronounce that repercussions
it's repercussions
let me see what you guys think here
honestly it sounds more evil you think
the the middle one sounds more evil
hallberry great option i mean harry is
still the hero and good but he knows the
crucio curse right right that's true
yeah i mean fake moody teaches it to
them in year four
but of course none of them
actually go and
they don't practice that one in class
you're a wizard harry
gazzie thank you for subbing to the
channel logan says i look at it more as
cowardice not evil personally
interesting so you're thinking the uh
raven as well welcome raven
teach me the cruciatus curse and i'll
cast it on you you think that one is
more
oh i lost your comment where'd it go
more cowardice huh
oh i could see that yeah like i don't
want to
i don't want to have it
i'm a coward because i'm not gonna take
the pain basically ah i could see that
i could see that feather says uh skyrim
doesn't really have a morality system
but i love it yeah i mean they can make
it work
and some people when they said it
there's no morality system that made
people more excited some people are a
little concerned i was a little
concerned at first and then they they
kind of clarified a bit more i just want
there to be consequences right if they
came out and said there are if they
confirm there are like let's say three
endings three possible endings
that would get me pretty pumped exactly
aj exactly i just saw your comment about
there's really very little point to
dialogue options if it doesn't lead to
multiple endings or even like a
different
you know something in this quest with
sebastian
happening differently
and you know the other part as i was
making my
my video about this
i started thinking about so the
unforgivable curses they were
unforgivable by this point
and they would have been in the
wizarding laws unforgivable
it was like i think 1717 when they
deemed them unforgivable so
just by using this guys
there should be a punishment
that would go
beyond the school punishment you would
think
michael thank you michael welcome
now the thing that we don't know for
sure is we don't know i mean in harry's
day
think about this guys
matthew thank you as well for the sub
in harry's day using an unforgivable
against another human
[Music]
get you a life sentence in azkaban think
about that dane thank you as well
now
knowing all that we we saw harry use the
unforgivables on more than one occasion
and who knows do they do they take
context
into account you know we we have laws
we're not gonna get into
you gotta be careful what you say on
youtube in terms of laws and things that
are legal and illegal but you know we
have laws where in certain circumstances
if you take a certain action
you you're okay you're good but if you
take that same action in other
circumstances then you'll be locked away
for a very long time
so it's interesting that the wizarding
world at least from the way it was
described in the potter series it
doesn't seem like there was that room
for
nuance there i mean because harry harry
is imperial in book seven i mean that
was like crucial to them
getting through uh and being able to
defeat voldemort i don't think anybody
was gonna lock him up in azkaban for it
uh same for when he casts crucio on
bellatrix so
but this right here it's like what are
the consequences gonna be clearly
the um
i think that guy's the professor
probably the gamekeeper
and maybe the uh care magical creatures
professor
but he basically is like the headmaster
is going to be notified immediately if
you guys are using dark magic
d jane hey d jane welcome maybe we have
to escape azkaban
i mean
you may not be far off
you may not be far off because
azkaban and the dementors are something
they've been like they haven't said
anything about
they showed
i think it's pretty clearly azkaban in
the very first reveal trailer
i think that is pretty clearly azkaban
and we also see the mentors
and then they they hadn't like said
anything about them so i was actually
beginning to wonder are they
are they in the game at all well then
they're the dementors are on the box art
you guys
they are on the box art for the game
which
i mean to me that confirms that
they're 100 sure going to be in the game
[Music]
let me go here and pull that back up
hey oni thank you so much for the super
chat
had a thought about choices and morality
in the game what if they have the
nemesis system from shadow of mordor
shadow of war
yeah so that is a i haven't seen anybody
ask that question lately but i feel like
when we first started um
hearing about hogwarts legacy a lot of
people were wondering that
because
that is something that for those of you
who haven't played any of the shadow of
mordor or shadow of war games
it was this idea of like
you going out throughout this world and
making certain enemies
that will then remember you
so i mean i think it could work in
hogwarts legacy i i don't think we've
seen enough yet
to be able to say
because it is going to be an open world
so i mean i think it could definitely
work
we just haven't seen enough yet really
to be able to take a good guess i don't
think so
yeah what else what else do you guys
think
or what what do the rest of you think
about that chances of seeing the nemesis
system
but here's the so here's the box art
right here and here's where you could
see the the dementors right here in the
bottom right
and that's that's been the biggest
question for everybody this whole time
is why would we
what would we be going to azkaban for
what would we be going to azkaban for
yo nico dude thank you so much for the
super chat can you post a link to the
order of merlin store have to take
advantage of that newsletter promo code
dude hey
definitely yeah so
it actually should be let me see if it
shows up here on youtube so
for those of you just maybe coming in
he's talking about so this shirt that
i'm wearing right here
order of merlin
ryan thank you so much for subbing to
the channel uh you guys can get this and
i have a newsletter
which my most recent one has a 10 off
code
gilderoy lockhart oh my goodness ladies
and gentlemen gilderoy lockhart has
subscribed to the channel so if you guys
go to my twitter twitter.com
retrorecordtour
and then right here start reading
you can subscribe to the to the
newsletter here we talk about video
games hogwarts all that sort of thing
and then at the bottom there's a 10 off
and the most recent one fire burn
subscribe to the channel as well and i
think i missed someone right there in
between apologies but thank you guys for
subbing to the channel
so um if you watch any video
oh it doesn't show up i don't know why
it doesn't show up
it's supposed to show up below
right beneath all my videos
the retro recontour shop but yeah i
probably should get that
probably should get that link out there
more
[Music]
let me pull it up i can't remember the
exact link for it but it's uh
it's all it's on teespring
anybody who would like can go and get it
man actually using the super chat
so show and support with the super chat
and then also wanting to go buy the
merch
very much appreciated dude thank you for
all the support
all right i am not a robot oh now i have
to select images of chimneys okay this
should be fun
there we go all right did i pass
yay i'm not a robot guys
oh that is not a valid login okay
this one should be
yep there we go
all right stores
okay there we go let's
copy that
all right now i can just post it right
here in the chat
okay so
retro
merch
store
[Music]
there you go
anybody interested there you go and if
you
hit that latest newsletter you can uh
get 10 off
yeah so here here are the shirts right
here
i wait until and it looks kind of blurry
i don't know why like the little preview
but in person it does not look like that
person it looks really nice
i actually love the quality
i made sure they were really they're
really soft that's why they're a little
bit
higher than like a normal shirt
um
like the only concern i have is i'm
wondering how this will hold up over
lots of washes because it kind of has
like this sort of a
little bit of a distressed kind of look
to it i mean ever so slightly
but yeah we got we got several plans for
uh some more shirts as well
and then you get it get it on like phone
cases coffee mugs stickers posters
and you get this hat that i'm wearing
right now if you want
you're not a robot either feathers nice
let's go
no robots here
yes i have been to hogsmeade it's
awesome
i haven't been back since they added
diagon alley though and i really need to
get back i went when they fur i mean it
i don't even think it had been open a
year
when i when i went to um
hogsmeade in diagon alley in orlando
oh it was so awesome though
dylan your shirt comes this weekend nice
yeah i'll say the uh
the shipping ended up being much faster
when i ordered mine because it said
something was gonna be like two weeks
like jeez this is crazy but yeah then it
came less than a week keelan i think a
nemesis system for the companions ah
now that
because see when i think of nemesis i
think of
you know someone like an antagonist
someone opposing you so yeah what if you
like
if you upset one of your companions then
how does it work from there
also feel that the game keeper would be
a part of that he seems to get more and
more annoyed
he does kind of get yeah both trailers
he's been like not happy
oh i like that idea brayden i like that
a lot the merlin puzzle things could be
like shrines and breath of the wild that
you can enter
dude we got miles morales in here as
well miles what's up new subscriber
thank you for subbing miles
hype for hogwarts legacy yeah most of
people are here as well
most of the people here are
tom has anyone ever told you
i
i don't think so
i've never played that game though
now i gotta look this up let's see we'll
let the chat be the judge
i'm gonna look it up in another window
though
can you come to lyrant's main character
oh they all there's a lot of different
looking dudes
oh maybe that's because he can grow like
facial hair and stuff
[Music]
oh yeah i think no that's definitely a
different guy right there
that's definitely a different guy
let me try
try a different search term here
see if we have better luck
oh henry okay kingdom come deliverance
henry
i could see it a little bit i could see
it
oh no
no i don't want to look like this guy
no i think there's just like there's not
really any good screenshots of this dude
there you go chat
i think this must be you can probably
like grow a beard throughout the course
of the game maybe
[Music]
hold on we need to do uh let's see open
image a new tab there we go
a little bit a little bit
ps1 retro oh man that's funny
hey oni thank you so much for the
support
hope you have a good uh morning day
evening at work
[Music]
have i ordered your latest book no
gilderoy
i've ordered the uh
the um art book though
scott thank you so much for subscribing
scott
you're a wizard harry
oh there's miles miles sub coming
through as well by the way anybody uh if
your messages get retracted
this is a family-friendly chat and it
will also block any
links as well
thirsty are you firsty
welcome thank you for subbing to the
channel as well you're a wizard harry
trace as well subscribing thank you so
much trace but yeah it will um
even if you put like a if you forget to
put a space after a period it will
detect that as a link
and then it will it'll block your your
comment ethan thank you as well
[Music]
all right so we talked about pre-order
we talked about the dialogue stuff which
the dialogue stuff
are we gonna see more soon
are we gonna see more
because
chandler wood hogwarts legacy community
manager has confirmed
we are getting more hogwarts legacy news
this week guys so we were so used to uh
getting nothing for a while then we got
used to these thursday updates
now
we're getting more than one update in a
week
getting more than one update in a week
and so this one right here
this is big people have been wanting
hogwarts legacy to do something back to
hogwarts for the past two years so for
those of you who may not be part of the
harry potter fandom
um this is a
this is a big celebration every year for
the whole harry potter community there's
lots of um
usually there'll be news and
announcements relating to the series at
these things and you know some some are
bigger than others um but we'll go
straight to the wizarding world website
here everything you need to know about
back to hogwarts 2022
oh well i didn't even need to give you
guys a description because here you go
right here what is back to hogwarts day
what is happening this year to celebrate
it and what would you get if we added
powder root of asphadel to an infusion
of wormwood all your burning questions
are answered here remember you can sign
up for the harry potter fan club
in the run-up to september 1st fans from
all generations come together to
celebrate a very special day in the
wizarding world calendar back to
hogwarts the day harry potter boarded
the hogwarts express and was whisked off
to the magical school that would change
his life here's your rundown on exactly
what it means to go back to hogwarts
uh concept has been celebrated for many
years now read our potted history of
previous events here oh i might actually
look at that in a minute
this year you can expect some fun
announcements fan celebrations and a
variety of spellbinding activities
to really get in the mood here's just
some of the things be them physical or
digital to look out for
all right so
i'm going to skip over a lot of these
you guys can go and
read them later if you want because
there's
there's actually quite a bit here this
is going to be interesting right here
i'm curious to see how these these uh
end up doing on youtube do you know
someone who is learning about the
wizarding world for the first time and
has absolutely no idea where to begin do
not fear our new easy explainer video
series will help your hogwarts studies
begin with a plum a plume
aplomb
never use that word
heard it know what it means but don't
know how to pronounce it
here you'll learn about the traditions
of the wizarding community the history
of the houses and the secrets of
hogwarts castle grab some parchment and
a quill
or
that might be a british thing
and be prepared to take notes we're
dropping new episodes across the coming
weeks the first episode can be seen here
oh i haven't even watched that yet
hashtag back to hogwarts wait dude do
they not even have the
do they not have any mention oh here it
is okay
oh i totally missed it i went right over
it
plot twist is that game will drop on
september 1st uh don't we all wish
all right so here we go a look ahead it
wouldn't be the start of term without an
announcement or two
brand new for this year fans are invited
to watch a special presentation crammed
full of news and updates highlighting
some of the exciting things the
wizarding world has in store so that
right there tells you it's not just
hogwarts legacy
um expect news on the upcoming rpg
console game sorry pc folks hogwarts
legacy
a first look at a particularly magical
product and spellbinding live
experiences which fans will not want to
miss tune in to youtube.com
c wizardingworld at 6 20
bst on november 1st to watch along
i have no idea what bst is so i'm gonna
have to look that up right now
bst to est
okay
no not pm i want
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
i don't want pm
yeah uk time
so that will be during the day for
eastern time right
me
okay that would be
1 20
eastern time
so in the afternoon so it's five hour
difference
for for me in eastern time
hey thank you david yeah 120 for us
thank you amore and david yep
so that'll be let's see that's not
tomorrow but that is thursday i think
yeah
yeah because everybody's been talking
for weeks and weeks about how
it's gonna fall on thursday it's gonna
fall on thursday
we gotta have something big for back to
hogwarts this year
so it is indeed happening guys it's
finally happening but what is it going
to be
let me know your predictions in the chat
what do you think what do you think
we're going to see i've got my
prediction
we don't know zone we don't know
uncut gameplay dude i wish it was
gameplay
i wish it was gameplay i don't think it
is
i'll i'll wait i want to wait and see
what some of the chat comments are first
before i tell you guys what i think it's
going to be
ravenclaw companion announcement jordan
want to see the hud
common rooms tour sorting
you think they'll show the same thing
we've already seen
um i don't think it'll be the ex no i
think it'll be new stuff for sure
definitely think it'll be new stuff
spellbinding means we're seeing the
spell casting system
oh do you think hold on let's go back to
that though because i think the
spellbinding comment
oh that was
i think the spellbinding comment was in
reference to something else though right
expect news on the upcoming rpg console
game hogwarts legacy a first yeah see
comma so this is something different
a first look at a particularly magical
product i think that is that whole um
harry potter magic
wand caster or whatever that they've
been teasing
um harry potter magic wand caster
[Music]
this thing right here
[Music]
get ready for the harry potter magic
caster wand i've not watched this
[Music]
magic is within your reach brings spells
to life
harry potter magic caster one
ultimate one experience i mean it sounds
like vr to me but a lot of people think
it's something with like a phone
some sort of phone thing instead
so i think that is what they're talking
about with a first look at a
particularly magical product
and spellbinding live experiences will
fans which fans will not want to miss
so i think though i think they're
talking about three separate things
right there
yeah i i think i think what if you
nailed it i think it's going to be the
final tab
so remember the character creator screen
that we have now seen but they they
didn't talk about that final tab
and chandler has already promised
this is the big thing chandler has
already promised
that they were going to show us i think
he even said the mysterious final tab
and it's a hogwarts symbol
what was that in was that the autodesk
presentation
let me pull see if i i know i've got a
screenshot of that somewhere
let's see here hogwarts legacy autodesk
yeah yeah yeah it was the autodesk
presentation
[Music]
all right so right here guys
so remember all these tabs
from the autodesk
and then this last one was the one that
we didn't see
[Music]
so we didn't see this last one and then
chandler tweeted out that we that they
would be showing that off at some point
so
i think it's going to be them finally
fully showing people how
sorting will work
and maybe
i've seen some other people say maybe
this and showing this tab whatever it is
whether it's just sorting whether it's
um
do you get to choose a pet to take to
hogwarts as well
because that's a big thing people have
been asking do we get to choose an owl a
cat or a toad because that'd be awesome
yeah the tweet after the autodesk yep
yep
back to hogwarts day suggests that we
may just get a look at how we start our
journey in hogwarts including that final
tab yeah yeah i think the final tab for
sure ezra they still haven't posted that
interesting
[Music]
hey demonic one welcome
still don't know what the last two cards
were in the skill tree yeah we still
don't know about the skill tree window
what did a1 kev say here
[Music]
oh your wife wants a wizard yeah wife
once a wizard's hilarious
yeah it would be the ravenclaw
showing off the final ravenclaw well i
shouldn't say final because we don't
know if it's gonna be final there might
be more than four companions
but showing off the ravenclaw company
would be another good one for sure
that'd be another good one
[Music]
and yes keelan i'm so glad you said that
yes yes yes
that i think is the big reveal
i think i think that is the big reveal
and i think that
steam kind of spilled the beans a little
bit and that's why it came down so
quickly
i have a screenshot of this saved on
i think it's my work computer and i know
james expecto go captured this live he
captured this live because
there were people in his chat saying
that hey steam has something up about
linking to your wizarding world account
so the day that pre-orders went live if
you missed this guys
the day that the pre-orders went live
and steam updated their page there was a
section over on the right
and it was like in this little kind of
yellowish gold box
and said i want to say it said requires
and then a lot of people are starting
asking channel like what's going on is
this required and he said no no no other
account is required
in fact i think he said it in that big
um
they might have answered that in their
big cat thank you so much for subbing to
the channel
let me check here
[Music]
when they answered all these questions
yeah right here this one here
because everybody saw this on steam but
notice their wording here a wizarding
world account or wb games account is not
required
i think not required
is the key word here
not required guys
i and and that to me is like a perfect
reveal
that's a perfect reveal for back to
hogwarts
because that is something since as long
as i've been covering this game
lovely thank you for subbing to the
channel
as long as i've been covering this game
the one thing that's people just
they just wanted so bad is they want the
ability to link
this
hogwarts legacy to their wizarding world
account
i think it could be happening
dylan yo dylan thank you so much for the
five dollar super chat
dylan always showing love and support to
the channel dylan thank you so much well
over 100 likes yo let's go need that
olive ender quote preferably spinning
oh man
i'll give you guys an olivander quote i
can't spin because i'm actually i'm
actually standing up uh tonight
i have i have a desk that can uh rise so
i'm in the standing position right now
because i've been sitting all day at
work
and so it was like
nah i'm gonna stand up tonight
but yeah expecto go does a thing on his
uh stream guys whenever he hit i think
it's 100 likes
he does a pureet and if he gets 150
he and sue to appear right if sue is
there
[Music]
tell me we can transfer our one to
patronus our house
amir like would that not be a perfect
back to hogwarts reveal
would it not be
see personally i never thought it would
happen
and i still even if it does happen
i don't think people should get their
hopes up on the patronus
because they're i mean how many patronus
patronai patronuses
how many patronuses are even
like possible in the wizarding world i
guarantee you somebody here knows
i just can't imagine that they would
program all of those into the game now
what i do think they could carry over is
your house
and your wand
your wand core
your wand would type
and then dude if they could get the
patronus
i mean
that'd be incredible
that would be incredible
oh there's a 142
are you serious
oh my gosh demonic one with the super
chat as well
demonic one thank you so much for
support of the stream over 350 let's go
guys
let's get those likes over 200
nice
let's do it
smash the like button
patronus is a mole i hope it does
yeah mine on the uh wizarding world site
is not something that i'm like
i can't even remember what it was now
was it like a
was it a tortoiseshell cat or something
oh i can't remember
my want i was i was happy with my wand
core and then i got i got gryffindor
but i can't remember i'm gonna look it
up right now
see what it is
it is
a
yeah tortoiseshell cat
what even is
like what do they say about that one
uh
oh they don't they don't have a
description
[Music]
but um
when i've taken other tests not the
official wizarding world when then i do
like all the tech all the questions i
get dolphin for my patronus
tortoiseshell
cat
patronus
[Music]
let's see here
[Music]
tortoiseshell coloring is possible i
don't care about that i want to know
what this patronus says about me
what does it say about me
what does your patronus say about your
personality
mugglenet
oh here we go
[Music]
george show cats have some of the
prettiest codes but don't let that fool
you these seemingly mild house cats pack
a lot of punch twitter show cats are
chatty strong willed and hot tempered
this is not me at all
they are very protective of their humans
so if your patronus is a tortoise shell
dementors had better watch out well but
then again i don't guess this has to be
i don't guess this has to be us this is
describing more the cat but yeah that
that doesn't fit me at all
destro for jordan
[Music]
bassett hound 220 likes yo let's go
all right for 220 likes for 220 likes
i'll give you guys my
i'll give you guys an ollivander
impression here
all right let's get the music
whoops you're a wizard harry you're a
wizard harry
andre thank you so much andre
all right so
you're a wizard this whole thing numb
thumbs thank you for subbing to the
channel this whole thing with the uh
ollivander quote for those of you who
are here doing this live stream you
already know this but uh crazy phoenix
as well
they always come in batches i think
whenever youtube live streams it just
like it batches them for a while twitter
twitch they come in real time jordan
thanks so much for subbing to the
channel
and then also on youtube i don't know if
it like
like is it only people subbing in this
live stream right now or could it be
people just watching some of my videos
and subbing randomly i have no idea
you don't know your patronus dude you
should go uh
go take the take the quiz
i'd love to make a separate email
account now and go and take it and see
what i got
uh if you just go to wizardingworld.com
keegan
and then you can do like um
yeah you should see this sorting it's
it's somewhere on on there but you can
go do the sorting
do all the questions for that and then
it'll you can do like your wand as well
it's pretty cool
so the uh the ollivander quote it
i just randomly did an olivander
impression in a video and then somebody
left a comment was like
never do this again it was a terrible
impression you're not good at it and you
clearly do not practice
it's like a heart i'm like
dude it was just meant to be a a funny
little
side thing
but yeah they took it very seriously so
so you know what we're gonna do we're
going to practice we're going to
practice here here on stream for
everybody here all right so
[Music]
i
wondered when i'd be seeing you mr
potter
seems only yesterday that your mother
and father are in here buying their
first ones
we'll give it a wave
no
definitely not
there wait wait what's the next line
oh it's uh it's um
curious
very
curious
i remember everyone i've ever sold mr
potter and it just so happens the
phoenix whose tail feather resides in
your wand
gave another feather
just
one
feather it is curious that you should be
destined for this wand
when its brother
gave you that scar
i need my wand
i need my wand dude
oh man
nailed it that's great john hurt would
be proud
oh man
thank you guys thank you yeah i need i
need to send it back to i need to find
that person in the comments
[Music]
young elevator okay yeah maybe a 95 year
old ollivander
[Music]
yeah i don't know why i just always like
doing the elevator impression so now the
next time somebody in the comments says
you clearly do not practice
just gonna be like dude
dude hold up
we've got the evidence we've got the
evidence to prove it we've been
practicing
[Music]
trying to think of some of my other
favorite harry potter ones i always love
doing the um
oh oh wait wait wait you remember the uh
the line from voldemort
oh what does he say what is it he says
to to wormtail he's like
dude whenever you do like ray finds you
gotta
you know you gotta you gotta work
yourself out for this one it's like um
step aside wormtail so i can give our
guest a proper greeting
oh man shadowing a shadow win thank you
so much for the super chat not great not
bad eight out of ten hey if it got
shadow in to do the super chat i'll take
it i will take that
i would have liked this video
hey thank you nicholas appreciated
this i mean maybe we just like
i just have to like find
a new um
oh yeah jay yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
oh man
georgios i'm probably mispronouncing
that my apologies bud thank you for the
sub arvin as well thank you for subbing
to the channel
yeah the the the voldemort one needs
needs more work for sure voldemort one
and i i mean i think we polish up the
olivander one a little bit we might we
might be able to get shadow and bump
that one up to like a nine out of ten
maybe nine out of ten
definitely worth staying
oh dude
240.
oh man
yeah if i ever have any off days at work
i need to do like a day stream so we
would probably get some more of our
overseas audience to be able to check
out some of the day streams but
right now unfortunately it's like 8 30
my time is is the best time i can do it
oh my gosh oliver cosplay dude
yeah the voldemort one is
tough on the throat a little bit
a good mad eye
oh let me think let me think
oh if i practice i think i could
probably do a pretty good dobby if i
practiced
master has presented dobby with clothes
mad eye though oh i'm trying to think of
some of the big like iconic mad eye
lines
oh are you a voice actor shadow guy
that's awesome dude
yeah lots of lots of water i've always
heard eating like eating an apple too
eating apple is good for like right
before you do a big big voice job
i've actually done a little voice acting
too just like for like um oh what is the
website up work
for like some small like mobile games
and stuff yeah
i've i've done some stuff there
it's a very good dobby dobby not that
bad hey that was that was just a quick
uh
that's what i'm saying i feel like if i
if i worked on the dobby we could get
dobby a pretty solid dobby
oh my gosh jake dude blast from the past
i i failed my first time so
no sweat dude no sweat
no man my first time was like a
nightmare it was just a nightmare i was
one of those weird like i didn't even
really
i had friends that drove me that like
could drive in high school so i didn't
have that like i feel like most high
schools it's like you can't wait to to
drive it's like a huge deal i mean it is
but i just like i don't know i just i
was fine like riding around with friends
so it wasn't like a huge deal for me and
then when i finally did it
i um
i didn't even have my own car yet so i
was taking my first driver's test in my
mom's van she had like this
enormous van
and yeah it just
it did not go well it did not go well
oh man
but yeah i'm sure you'll be fine
i'm sure i'm sure it'll be fine no
worries
nah dude just take your time you'll be
good always i mean anytime you're
driving the easiest thing to remember is
like always air on the side of caution
right like if you're not if you're not
sure
if you should go just just wait
that's what happened to me we were at
this um
i guess it was like a little it was a
pretty busy intersection and there were
there were so many so many cars coming
we waited forever
and
we waited waited and waited and then
there was like a little gap but not
enough so i didn't go
then we kept waiting waiting waiting
and then there was like a little bit of
a bigger gap and i was like okay i think
i think i'm good so i pulled out and the
ladies like
you just pulled out in front of a truck
and i was like
no
no
i mean it wasn't like it was kind of in
front of me you know but i should have
just waited that's
if i just waited it would have been fine
hey chicken thank you for stopping by
and hanging out
yeah i on in all seriousness no like
just just take your time
that's that's the biggest lesson i can
say
as long as you pronounce it's leviosa
not levio saw
oh david yes i should work on that one
you sound like dobby doing a voice of
him and good job dobby doing a voice of
himself
oh dude you know which one i would i
would love if i could like if i could
get a good hagrid
you got to get deep though you're going
to get really scared for that one yeah i
mean there he is right there retro elite
gamer
you got to get pretty deep
need another place to put your chewing
gum besides the underside of your oh
yeah that's a good line rossi that would
be a good one to practice
jordan mad eye is the one you could do
when you read the book to your son
that's awesome man
my son loves when i i do different
voices too when we read together
osiris gaming a osiris welcome pre-order
digital deluxe on ps5 cannot wait until
february 7th i know right we should i
guess we could start saying february 7th
is the new release date for for most of
us right
shadow guide i will never learn to drive
oh i just lost the comment
it bumped down
where'd it go
oh there it is adhd and autism adhd and
autism lack of attention span would
crash every 30 seconds oh wow
i mean
yeah it's
i have an uncle who is
he drives and he has cerebral palsy and
and they told him he would never be able
to drive so i mean you never know i
don't know there could be it could be
some advances that would help you out
but it sounds like that
honestly it sounds like it's the way
you're describing it there it's better
for for your safety there
16 is scarier than the driving test you
got this right
almost got t-bone yesterday drive from
home at work because someone almost ran
a red light oh yikes
[Music]
dude cars are terrifying really
i honestly shadow guide you just like
hit on something with me there i
remember going to my dad when i was a
young
i can't remember how old i was but it
was like because if you watch like
nascar right like nascar
is to the point now they have had deaths
in the past but it's to the point now
where like those cars are so
ridiculously safe
and so it's like so wait we have the
technology
where we could we could literally make
every car that's safe
but
we don't because you know money
right
money
so it's just like we have the technology
out there to literally
prevent almost every single yeah yeah
it's
it's crazy though don't don't think
about it too hard
instructor told me you failed trying to
be funny oh wow
that's just harsh right there jordan you
didn't get yours until you were 23. wow
jason nearly rolled your grandmother's
fans you gotta relate
yeah i was like i'm not driving this
this van anymore
not driving this van christopher took
off wednesday through friday for a
release oh man i think i might have to
take the whole week
it depends on if we
i i have no idea if they're gonna send
out review codes or
if they would send them out to youtubers
or if they would just go to like
the big video game folks but hey
so i have i have no idea what my week
will look like but it's like
that's gonna be so hard deciding what
videos to make first
what do you guys think that's actually a
great poll let me put up a poll for that
all right so our first poll we had a
poll earlier guys that was um have you
pre-ordered hogwarts legacy so we had
six percent say yes the standard edition
48
wow have already pre-ordered the digital
deluxe edition or just the deluxe could
be digital or
uh regular
and then five percent said yes
collectors edition wow so it's all five
collectors and standard almost the same
and then 41 still no
all right so i'm gonna go ahead and end
that poll
and so now i'm gonna make a new poll
here
so let's fast forward in time guys
it is
let's say it's about a week after launch
because i know most of you in the chat
right now are not you will not want to
be spoiled i don't feel like
so you're gonna hop once once you've had
a time to experience the game
then you hop back online you head over
to youtube you go over to youtube.com
slash retraction tour
what is like the first video you would
want to see me from me which video
would you want to see from me
first
after playing
hogwarts legacy
so let's see here what should we how
should we break this down so let's just
let's just say review just like a
general review
that'd be a good one
get a review of the game
um i'm gonna say a lore
slash
uh how should i phrase this one like a
lore
lore breakdown
how about lore slash story
breakdown
anything with no story spoilers
jay rossi says some of the secret po oh
that that's
i think you just hit it d jane i think
that's the one everybody would want
secrets
yeah castle see
i'll i'll put it in the poll but i feel
like this one's gonna win castle secrets
um
gameplay
[Music]
tips
oh and that's it we can only do four
options no way
an intro video
um
expand on that one a bit feathers
what do you mean like an intro to the
story
or an intro to
the game like the gameplay
yeah i feel like hidden item oh actually
instead of just saying secrets i'm gonna
say
um secrets
and
let's oh i should put let's play up i'm
going to do tips secrets
include those as one
and then the other one i'm gonna say
let's play i wish i could honestly if i
if you have one that's not in the
category
still throw it out there in the chat but
it only lets me do four options so
here's it's gonna be uh which video
would you want to see for me first after
playing hogwarts sexy a general review
lore slash story breakdown tips and
secrets or just the let's play
ask your community boom there we go
oh that was i'm glad we whoever threw
that
idea whoever started talking about
release of the game
thank you i think that's a that was a
good one
bug bug compilation would be cool yeah
jake i'm changing my date and time on
xbox to be able to play it early
nice let me know if that if that works
out
retro aking everyone oh my gosh
looking for chamber of secrets oh my
gosh dude
easter eggs there's going to be so many
easter eggs in this game
yeah i want to do like a full walk
through a mirror for sure
[Music]
first hour of gameplay jason says i like
that idea
uh feathers let's see you were
you're expanding on that and saying both
story and gameplay okay gotcha maybe
some tricks
somebody was asking i saw something
about will i be and expect to go stream
uh almost certainly yeah i always try
and pop in at least for a little bit of
um
expecto go stream say hello to everybody
and hang out for a bit i love chatting
with him and sue
um dj and retro i really want to watch
you play when it comes out i think i'm
gonna have to restrain myself i i get
that
i get that dee jane because i
i'm expecting that because i know so
many of the people who watch this stream
and who support the channel are like die
hard fans
we don't want to be spoiled
so
i get that that's why i honestly i still
can't decide if i want to stream the
game
or not
i can't decide if i want to stream the
game because i feel like the majority of
you wouldn't be watching
because you're going to be playing the
game
it's different when it's like a
multiplayer game you know
maybe like a week after the launch or
something
i don't know so if you guys have
thoughts on that
but then again i mean i guess i could
just i could just stream and for people
who want to watch they can watch and for
people who don't
are still playing they're still playing
that's possible too
[Music]
feathers taking your apparition test
[Music]
oh
my buy socks and use them to free
households
yeah so a mori poet sorry i missed your
i missed this question earlier but yeah
i was trying to frame it in the way that
you've already finished the game
so like a week after hogwarts legacy is
out
you're done with the game
you're ready to hop on youtube now
you're ready to hop on twitter see what
people are saying
because i mean i feel like a lot of
you guys are going to be going dark
right like just like i don't want to
i don't want to see anything
um
if i get the game early if i'm if i'm
lucky enough i'm fortunate enough to
actually get a review code early
then i would have
a spoiler free
impression slash review which
whatever that may be
dean got confused contact with my
distributor no response yet ordered the
collector's edition 72 hour head start
collector's edition is a physical box
imagine they will email
no dean so
you'll definitely need to talk to the
retailer about that chandler wood
answered this on twitter to a it might
have been a direct reply to
somebody um
they will ship early
so
the deluxe editions and the collectors
editions just think of their release
date as the seventh
think of their release date as the
seventh so they will be in retailers on
the 7th
so
usually i mean i've had a really good
experience with amazon getting me things
the day of i've had really good
experience with best buy honestly your
best bet would be probably to do like an
in-store pickup
at a place like best buy
best buy or target we still haven't seen
pre-orders pop up yet
um i know walmart's been doing pretty
good with their
their stuff as well but i've always had
like picking it up day day of launch
if you don't want to take the chance on
amazon
because
amazon like i said they're good most the
time but you're you're playing a risky
game you know
shipping crazy things can happen
so sorry i missed a couple of those
let's scroll back up official
b and
b
b
nate asian b nation official b nation
i'm doing well how are you thank you for
hanging out
castle secrets lily potter says
no way will i finish hogwarts legacy in
a week oh no definitely not
couple weeks
[Music]
hey david
i don't know if you're already gone or
not david but thank you uh thank you for
stopping by
have a good night
oh yeah whatever your time frame is you
know because obviously i'll have to be
making i'll be making videos
as
i
i don't want to say as quickly as i can
as efficiently as i can would be a
better way of saying it
[Music]
oh character creation somebody said
character creation that would be a good
one
[Music]
um
[Music]
is it going to be a global launch or is
it going to be when each time zone gets
there on launch date so what most games
do this is just in the us so i don't
know
but like for me i'm on eastern time
so at midnight my time
it goes live so it would actually go
live at nine on the west coast
that's what
most companies do over here
matthew rowan matthew thank you for
subscribing to the channel
[Music]
confirm house points uh i don't think
it's been confirmed i'd be shocked if
it's not in there though
el mucho grumpy what are your thoughts
on the ps4 collector's edition not
including a crosston upgrade to ps5
oh you're right
[Music]
you're right i had not even thought of
that
yeah only the uh only the digital ones
oh dude that that is something they
probably should have included
but i guess they're like well it's ten
dollars cheaper
[Music]
uh that's kind of unfortunate yeah
[Music]
doing a pickup at best by day of really
wanted a physical version of deluxe yeah
yep i've usually had pretty good success
with with best buy getting day of
and guys honestly day of you're probably
going to be able to walk in and buy a
wait a second that's a that's an
interesting question too because it's
doing the three-day early access
so will they i wonder if retailers
i hadn't thought about this will
retailers be getting
extra copies of the deluxe edition like
on the 7th
or will every single copy that they have
be allocated to a specific pre-order
hmm
i had not thought of that
i feel like they would have extra
that people could pick up in store on
the seventh but only the deluxe edition
i don't know maybe not
anywhere in the exclusive amazon hat
no and i looked because the amazon this
is the first time that the amazon orders
have been live
on uh
at least in the us so today is the first
time i've seen them so i'm on the page
right now so if you go to ps5
it does have the bit about the exclusive
quest but then it doesn't say anything
about that hat
doesn't say anything about that hat
and for anybody who may be watching and
is like what the heck are they talking
about um
i believe it was amazon france and
amazon germany you're a wizard
zeo thank you for subscribing
there is a hat i think it's called um
astronomers hat it's like a purple hat
with stars on it here i'll see if we can
pull it up here
[Music]
astronomers hat hogwarts legacy
yeah here's the reddit post for it
and this is i mean it's legit in the
sense that
you can go to the amazon
yeah it looks like the reddit mods are
still waiting on confirmation too it's
on the fringe and german amazon website
so far post has amazon edition yeah this
is probably the strangest part
let me see if it'll let me open this up
here
yeah
so obviously i can't personally read a
lot of this but we can make this part
out right here edition amazon
and then
uh let's see right there so it's it is
still up on amazon
france and germany
this hat right here but the u.s
versions went up today
and there's nothing
and they did not even address that
that's not one of the questions they
answered in their big long twitter post
kind of addressing a lot of the concerns
they didn't mention that at all so i
have no idea they said we'll be getting
more on the the playstation exclusive
stuff
but we got nothing on the amazon stuff
so i don't know maybe it could be a
territory thing
a couple of months more than likely to
beat this game yeah
respect to patronum is one of the charms
on chalkboard yes yes there's a lot of
them on there uh linus a lot of them
it'd be insane if the game includes
everything that's on that board
i'd love it gonna do a sorting quiz or
you don't want
to anymore
uh what do you mean
i have a um i have a video on my channel
of me doing a sorting quiz
so yeah i mean if they give you the
option i'll do it in hogwarts legacy
like if they actually ask questions or
something i'll do it
but um
otherwise i'll just go straight to
gryffindor
i've gotten that pretty much
95 of the time
any test i've ever taken i got ravenclaw
like one time on something but yeah i'm
almost always gryffindor
hello abu hey big fan thank you so much
dude appreciate you stopping by and
hanging out
[Music]
uh keelan a lot of people think we could
be going to a death day party
i don't think it's a job for nick
necessarily i think it's
he says the character says don't forget
why i'm here sir
so it's like our character is wanting to
get
[Music]
get something from helping nick we don't
really know what
thank you david appreciate you hanging
out
imagine you have to go with proof of
purchase in the actual store to get your
copy of your game early uh yeah or i
mean like if you have the
most retailers like when you pre-order
it has like your name on it and then you
have to show um
show id or something to pick it up
zeo knox do i think the collector
edition is worth it
no
no i do not
am i going to shame people that buy it
no i mean if you have the disposable
income and you want to go for it go for
it but i do not think it's worth it
if i was not covering the game somebody
asked me on twitter like what am i doing
i did i did manage to get a pre-order of
the collector's edition in but i just
complete being completely truthful with
you guys if i was not covering the game
as much as i was for for youtube and for
you guys
i would not get the collectors
in fact i told expect ago i'm actually
i'm thinking about maybe like
either doing a channel giveaway after
i'm done with it or like maybe um
one thanks so much for subscribing or
just selling it at cost to somebody
somebody who really wants it just
selling it at cost
and and that's like
i mean you guys know i'm like super die
hard fan for this game and for for me to
be saying that
it's just like i don't know it just
i actually like the idea of the floating
wand i do i think that's kind of cool
but i was real disappointed in when they
did the unboxing the quality of it just
does not look
up to par and then that's like
that's it
it's like steel book man
itching included like at least three
more things i mean bare minimum for 300
it should have included soundtrack and
it should have included the art book
which the art book on amazon is still
listed for like 50 40 45 50 or something
so that art book must be a pretty high
quality art book that those two things
would have made
then you start to get much closer to
being worth that 300.
if it had been 200
i would have said
okay
you know don't love it still don't love
the contents of it but 200 fair price
300
no
somebody was saying um when do
pre-orders end up pretty much pre-orders
go all the way up to launch
all the way up to launch
of a game
feathers i ordered the collector's
edition and think it was a ripoff
yeah me too
that's uh that's the boat i'm in as well
yep
oh maury poet on the left-hand side
profile oh yeah tell him how to find the
yeah on the wizarding world stuff
ten times six times slytherin three
times ravenclaw one gryffindor so
anybody who's worrying about the the
house stuff and you're like ah i don't
know i can't decide remember
the sorting hat takes your choice into
account so if you're one of these people
who always gets kind of like a you're
like a 50 50 or a 60 40
just go with the one you want
just go with the one
that's it
morgan's a hufflepuff
i did i did pre-order a collector's and
also a deluxe just in case i decide to
honestly
because the um
one of the other reasons i pre-ordered
to a deluxe and a collectors is if the
collectors for some reason doesn't show
up because it's a game stop and it's
shipping to my house
i was trying to get it through so
frantically i didn't even get to set it
as the um
in-store pickup
so it may not get to my house on the
seventh
so i did go ahead and pre-order a deluxe
at best buy two
when is the trailer mr dooley
uh which trailer
the back to hogwarts thing
here is the
here's the back to hogwarts info right
here
this is a 1 20 eastern time by the way
looks like duct tape
being ripped off your arm
pre-order stand for ps4 nice nice final
fantasy vii remake first class edition
had the game steel book art book
soundtrack plastic toy centerpiece sold
at 3 30
playstation thing two
yeah the the god of war collectors
editions both of them just like
put the hogwarts legacy one to shame
honestly hey jake thanks for hanging out
have a good night dude
jason slytherin jamie proud to be a
slytherin dude we always have lots of
slytherins in the house
hey waltina
another channel member good to see you
had to get the deluxe edition on ps5 and
pc pc because i think mods will be
amazing oh right
the mod scene is going to be very very
interesting for the game
i always kind of knew i was gryffindor
ezra
always kind of knew
what 6 20
i know right i have no idea
maybe they're going to do a 10 minute
countdown
and keep in mind guys this is not just
hogwarts legacy
it's gonna be
more than more than just hogwarts legacy
so i have no idea what to expect in
terms of like duration like how much
time is going to be devoted to hogwarts
legacy uh scott nothing officially but
any game that's on pc if if there's
enough interest people will find a way
to mod it
people will 100 find a way to mod it
everybody likes to talk a lot about mods
support
i mean
if the if the devs fully like embrace
modding and and mods then yeah you could
do some really special stuff but
even if they don't do anything there
will still be mods if enough people love
this game
ps1 hagrid right yeah
compared to collector editions like
exactly
exactly compare it to so many other
collectors editions in it yeah it's it's
pretty big disappointment
i did a video gosh probably over a year
ago i mean it was a long time ago of
what i would like to see in a hogwarts
legacy collector's edition and i said up
front like i'm not saying everything in
this i'm just throwing out some ideas
and then after they actually announced
the collectors people went back on that
video and were like uh yeah so
this turned out to be pretty
disappointing right
uh matt we talked a little bit about
that earlier i think they're gonna do
something with
i think it's gonna be something to do
with sorting and showing off that final
tab
of the of this right here
i think we're going to get a look at
what is in this final tab because it's
the hogwarts crest
then i think the tab relates to the
sorting
and then here's my here's my big
would be insane incredibly awesome
prediction
is
i think
that tab is also going to have the
option to link to our wizarding world
account talked about that a little bit
earlier
think they're gonna do it man i think
they're gonna do it
hey fernandez
welcome what's up always recognize that
name
i do not know how to pronounce your
first name i apologize duarte
duarte fernandez
but i always see you in the comments i
always uh always appreciate your
comments on the videos dude thank you so
much glad you got to stop by for a live
stream
oh yeah shadow shadow that's another
great point yeah it's it's an engine
that people are very very familiar with
[Music]
yep don't have to worry about any
anti-cheat stuff either
you're a wizard harry
mr hooded raven
thank you for subbing to the channel
hufflepuff on my first chat first test
will not do a
retake hufflepuff through and through
makel mikel nicholson thank you so much
for subbing
260.
what's that oh 262 likes let's go
we already did the olive and impression
we did multiple impressions guys
hassam thank you for subscribing to the
channel
no they've clearly said there's not
going to be any multiplayer in the game
i still have a small hope that maybe
down the line if this continues to stay
popular they'll do an online version
i thought that for a while dee jane i
really did i don't think so anymore but
but but but but
i do think
i feel like wb if they're smart
they have to be hearing the rumblings
for that
they have to be hearing the desire for
multiplayer so i don't know if it would
come from avalanche and from hogwarts
legacy
i kind of feel like they'd be better
focusing which who knows yet we haven't
played the game but
maybe if they let them stay focused on
the story driven
and then have
another company
another dev
finally build a harry potter
mmo
we'll see
that would be far down the line but
want the pc version but you want the
exclusive quest to recipe right yeah i'm
gonna be playing on ps5 most likely
there are some days i'm still tempted
i'm still tempted for pc honestly if if
like
for those of you like kind of on the
fence about ps5 or pc you do have the um
the exclusive quest consider
and the felix felicis potion we don't
know if it's timed exclusive yet and we
don't know if it's a i mean this could
be like a five minute i don't think it'd
be five minutes but it could be very
minor requests or it could be something
that like is actually really epic and
cool we just don't know
the other thing we don't know is you
definitely want to
one of my favorite channels for like
breakdowns of
performance on games is digital foundry
they will almost certainly have
something up about
how this game runs
uh with a lot of games you know if you
have a good pc you're almost always
going to get better performance there
almost always
theoretically you should
but then a lot of times there are games
the games run like
just like almost as good on ps5
and so as long as hogwarts legacy is
like that i will most likely be playing
on ps5
if the pc version just ends up being far
and away better and like the ps5 version
has problems or something or a bad frame
rate then yeah i would probably go the
frame rate honestly will probably decide
if it doesn't run it like a pretty
steady 60 on ps5 60 frames per second
then i'll go pc
um
but they we know dude where did we have
it confirmed
they confirmed somewhere
that there's going to be a performance
mode
i can't remember where i read that
but i know they confirmed that somewhere
[Music]
hogwarts castle walk through for back to
hogwarts day
haptic feedback yeah that's another
thing consider owen we don't know for
sure yet if it will be supported on pc
red linus
hey thank you so much red linus
appreciate it yeah i'm just
as i say in a lot of my videos i'm just
a dad who loves games and the stories
they tell
i i've been a fan of harry potter for so
long that
i've been looking forward to this game
for a long time so we try to keep it
positive focus on the focus on the
positive things don't get into so much
the
all that extra stuff
there there's enough problems in the
world right i mean when
that's who my channel is for really you
know when you guys
come to my channel you're you're wanting
to at least the way i envision it is
people are going to escape from a lot of
that real world stuff so it's like we
just want to enjoy some games man
she want to enjoy some video games
that's right ezra yes i knew i'd seen
that somewhere so on the playstation
blog with the ps5 immersion trailer so
that gives me hope that there will at
least be a version on ps5 that runs at
60fps
[Music]
uh matt says how would a performance
mode work don't know exactly what that
means yeah so
with a lot of games on ps5 and the new
xbox
the consoles haven't had this for years
you know pc has always had this where
you could turn down settings and you get
better performance
so when people say performance they're
talking about a games usually talking
about a game's frame rate so how smooth
it runs and for years it was like
console was kind of stuck at 30 and then
every now and then you would have a game
that was 60 fps and it would just
be incredible
on console and it's a personal
preference thing too some people prefer
resolution some people prefer better
frame rate
and so
a a top of the line pc
is the only place that you will get like
the maximum at both where you have like
great frame rate
and i'm talking like high-end pc
um
it's the only place where you're gonna
get all those so what they've done on
these newer consoles is they give people
the option
by programming into these games a number
of different modes so they usually call
them uh one is called a performance mode
that one is the is the one that will run
at a slightly lower resolution so maybe
it runs at 1440 or
some sort of scale down like there's
not gonna get too technical with it
checkerboarding and all that stuff
but um it will run scaled down so the
visual fidelity maybe they turn down
some of the effects they won't be as
good
but the game will run smooth
ratchet and clank and spider-man are two
of the recent ones that you could go
online and find some good pretty good
demos and breakdowns of
um i personally almost always prefer the
performance modes i want my game to run
smooth the effects can be turned down
for me i don't i don't really mind that
as much
and then the other mode they usually
call like a fidelity mode and so with a
fidelity mode that's the one that's
going to focus on giving you the best
possible graphics the best possible
resolutions on ps5 you're going to be
getting 4k
and then the game may run at a 30 frames
per second instead of 60.
um
there are also
some new
now that ps5
this is like getting way technical but
now that ps5 supports vrr
there are also some interesting things
that some folks are doing like ratchet
and clank where
they're able to run the fidelity mode
at a higher frame rate than before like
like 45 fps instead of 30. so digital
foundry is where you want to go for all
this i don't even fully understand it
all thank you so much for that sub by
the way that just came in
but basically you're looking at do you
want better frame rate or do you want
better graphics that's the way of
simplifying it so that's what
a lot of the games are doing now is they
give you the option
hey thank you waltina yeah we keep it
positive here
[Music]
oh man you guys are rolling in with the
comments
someone mod in the exclusive potion for
pc
[Music]
trying to get back in my fan fiction all
of it is harry potter bass oh you
actually uh like writing fanfiction
jason that's cool
[Music]
mention of the game that shall not be
named
[Music]
i can't remember what i what game i
mentioned rossi
i'm probably so far behind in chat right
now
[Music]
nico i work in criminal law deal with
the worst of humanity oh man
retros videos make that less stressful
nice being in such a nice community we
all just love games and the stories they
tell hey nico thank you so much dude
yikes yeah i'd say you do see a lot of
uh
not so happy things
yeah and then like my wife she's a a
nicu nurse
neonatal icu so those uh for those who
don't know that's like the really really
sick babies who are born super early
so i think about people like that you
know people that work in the medical
field people that work you know working
in criminal things people that
i mean just have like these really rough
jobs and then when you come home it's
like let's just
you know or you get a break at work you
want to and you hop on a youtube video
for a bit
yeah i worked with the public for a long
time too
state government for uh maury poet there
[Music]
hey thank you guys yeah that's honestly
like i love hearing you all say that
that's exactly what
it's exactly what i was going for and
really one of the main reasons i started
a youtube channel in the first place
really is to try and build a community
like that where
because it's like man so many people in
life like they don't have
i was so blessed growing up to have like
close friends and a family
that like loved and supported me and
encouraged me and then
working in the public for like the past
eight to ten years as i have it's like
dude you it's really a wake-up call that
not not everybody has that not even the
majority have that
and so it used to be like when internet
was first kind of forming it sort of was
like this weird sort of
what do they call it like a parasocial
relationship i think it's like where
um
i can't remember the exact definition
but it's like where you don't know the
person
actually in person
but now it's like those bears are kind
of breaking down you know it's like
it's still a parasocial relationship but
like this is a you know
this community it's a real thing you
know we can chat and hang out on youtube
and hang out on twitter hang out in
discords play games together all these
sorts of things so
sorry you guys
that's a that's a fun uh
digression to go down but
oh that game jay rossi that game i
gotcha yeah we're not gonna we're not
gonna mention that game right now
christopher you're a nurse too nice
[Music]
yeah
my wife has uh
has some really tough days for sure but
she loves it it's like
she's actually right where she wants to
be she always wanted to be a nicu nurse
[Music]
oh wait did we get a theory did somebody
drop a theory in here
keelan do you know how you said our
character is drawn to hogwarts what if
merlin is our character's descendant
dude that's all i expected hey hey
talk about merlin though
wait hold on
[Music]
talk about merlin guys
[Music]
pretty cool right
pretty cool
you guys can if anybody's interested you
can get that in the uh official retro
rack into her shop
[Music]
let me post another link because
somebody actually asked for it earlier
and that's when i realized like you know
what you're i don't really
post that in a lot of places
i probably should make it easier and
it's supposed to appear below my youtube
videos but
for some reason it doesn't show
there so i don't really know what
happened there and why it
stopped showing
[Music]
all right
gotta log back in
but yeah i think
i mean we already know merlin is for
sure confirmed as being at least part of
the game through the puzzles right
we'll see when the game launches how uh
how accurate expected go has been
how are you star geezer tim hey tim
thank you so much for becoming a channel
member
you just unlocked
all those slick new emotes which
somebody reminded me earlier speaking of
merlin we're gonna merlin is going to be
our next emo we've unlocked
we've got another emote slot we actually
have a couple but i don't have ideas for
all of them yet so one of them is
definitely gonna be merlin
so welcome welcome my friend thank you
so much for supporting the channel there
wait why can i not
oh i closed the wrong window
i closed the wrong window
nope you guys don't want to see that
that would be
that would be really confusing because
there'd be like three chats on the
screen
okay there we go
yeah i should probably just start
putting this in like
the description or something of videos
dude we got 285 people right here what
is up man what is up to the lurkers out
there thank you all so much for hanging
out
and chatting hogwarts legacy it's
amazing like i
i don't really
i don't know if you guys can tell or not
maybe i shouldn't
divulge this but when i go into these
each week i don't really put together a
i put together like three
three or so topics that i want to cover
like big topics that have happened
around hogwarts legacy lately
and then we just go i mean we just
that's it that's the only structure i
see where see where the chat leads me
you know
amir how much time do i think i'm going
to spend on character
customization probably
yo starkeezer tim just gifted five
memberships oh my gosh i forgot they
even added that to youtube dude that is
awesome tim thank you so much for that
how do we see
i gotta figure out how
oh i wonder if there's a way to tell who
got the gifted memberships
[Music]
what does that mean so
if you're familiar with twitch twitch
has like where you can gift a sub to
people so youtube has now where you can
gift a membership to people so
memberships on youtube are a little bit
more open in terms of like i can kind of
make the perks what i want
and so right now when you become a
member you get access to those new
um
yeah i guess the only way it's like
i guess that's the only way shadow oh we
got two shadows we got shadow in and we
got shadow guide i guess the only way to
tell is like to see if you have the uh
oh there it goes it's popping up now
idk was gifted a membership oh they're
all going to start popping up now
let's go
dude star geezer thank you so much
hey if you if any of you got a gifted
sub or gifted membership rather and
you're active in the chat make sure you
uh
give star geezer a thanks there that's
very much appreciated um
but yeah so right now we only have one
tier i think it's like 499 and when
you're on that tier you get all the
emotes that you can use
there we go rain duff gifted a
membership also scott ferris gifted a
membership
so right now all of you who just got
that membership you'll have access to
um
there is like a members only group on
youtube to where there's not a lot of
stuff in there yet but like if i wanted
to put out a video
just for members i could do that um if i
wanted to put out um i have done a
couple of comments a couple of um
community posts that just go out to
members
[Music]
done that as well but right now the big
thing is the uh
is the emotes super art as well getting
a gift of membership
[Music]
scott ferris did i miss that one scott
gifted a membership as well
and then rain so yeah there's the
there's the five one two three four oh
no wait
there's still going to be one more there
it is jamie meyer
getting the gifted membership as well
nice nice oh yeah and then
scott also reminded me right there so
see how by scott's name he has the
little retro
icon so you get a badge so that's the
badge that'll show up by your name and
then you also get the little emoji that
you can use in chat the emoji that nico
just used the uh
serpent lion eagle and badger
pk 45 aegis sub saw all the harry potter
content on your page and i thought how
could i not sub hey pk thank you so much
very much appreciate that
yeah it's i wish it was faster on uh
youtube live there's a little bit of a
delay
so your sub will pop up here in a second
oh it feathers
feathers becoming a member as well
feathers mcgraw thank you so much
feathers i see you all the time and uh
expecto goes
live streams as well thank you so much
welcome to tier one
but yeah if you guys so those of you who
are now members if you have any ideas
for other
perks you'd like to see
another dude the memberships
we've got like a
hype train going right here
duarte
fernandez
tier one member thank you so much
and everybody saying thanks for the
gifted as well nice uh
feathers mcgraw is the best wallace and
granite character
i think we could hit 300 likes
let's go dude oh we're at 274. nice
noise we've got we've had 11 new members
in this stream that's amazing and i saw
i think i saw from the attic there as
well
from the attic welcome welcome
hey hey glad to be able to jump in on
the stream a bit late oh it's all good
it's all good they're late night streams
i get that some people early morning
depending on
depending on where you're at in the
world
[Music]
but yeah there is a um
[Music]
there's a section that you can now for
for those of you who are members if you
go onto my page you'll be able to see
like if you go into the community
section actually let me see if it'll
will even let me look at my own
so like if i go to
my own channel here
and then yeah like so like right here is
the community area
and then
so this is what it looks like to me
so yeah you would just go here and so
for those of you who are members you
would be able to see any posts that i
like like i could go in here right now
this is a test post and then i can
change the visibility so i could have it
set to all channel members tier one and
higher we only have one tier right now
so it's it's all channel members
so if you um you know if you have any
ideas you can leave a comment on one of
these members only areas if you want
yeah we do have we do have several other
emote slots unlocked
we just have to uh i just have to put in
the the files for them i already have
one for sure we're going to be doing the
merlin
the merlin
[Music]
oh my dog just came in
[Music]
see if she'll come up here and say hello
most of you uh
oh come on you gotta look there it is
there's no cameras up there
[Music]
oh man she needs a grooming she's
getting a little shaggy
[Music]
by the way
i bet you guys can never guess where we
came up with that i bet you can never
guess where we came up with that name
no
you're a wizard
totally camera shy tonight
look at her dude she's like i did not
want this
yeah so i uh
this i'm in my office and the door opens
the doors back there
and it has like
you can almost see it right yeah you can
almost see it right there it's just out
of the frame
but it has like the little um windows
where you can see through and dude if i
shut that door she does not like it
she does not like it at all
oh a mori poet by the way i just saw
yeah
no worries at
all hey it's it's it's crazy times right
now so yeah guys do not feel any sort of
obligation to uh
become a member or donate or anything
like that that is just a way for people
to show some extra love who if they
if they have the funds to do so so
sub it's kind of backwards like on
youtube it's subs are free on twitch you
pay for subs are the paid one
on youtube it's memberships that you
paid for so the terminology is a little
weird but yeah i don't want anybody to
ever feel like
honestly like your guys support of the
channel is
more than enough support
hanging out chatting
yes west highland terrier yeah yeah
i hope we need a love good
that makes you think of uh luna lovegood
3 a.m here portugal oh my goodness
hey thank you so much for becoming a
member though have a good one
oh yeah a mori poet no no sweat no
worries at all
and we got nico gifting a uh membership
as well dude this is kind of fun it's
like
it's like who's gonna get the who's
gonna get the gift of membership
there's that little bit of a delay there
where we wait
we wait we see is it gonna is it gonna
pop up
come on where's it at
marvin oh my gosh marvin what is up dude
marvin escalante ladies and gentlemen
marvin was a big supporter back in my
twitch days when i was streaming to
about
five people a stream
marvin how you been doing man
shadow guy nearly 4am oh my gosh we got
we've got like a crazy uh
worldwide audience here hanging out
keelan hanging out at 3 30.
3 35 a.m
ah boqueto got the gift of membership
nice nico thank you so much for showing
the love
sharing it with some others here
locato getting the gifted membership
it's completely random ah gotcha okay
if you want the membership make sure to
hit the allow gifts button in the live
chat oh is that for the other
i saw somebody say that earlier nico so
that's not me i don't have to hit that
that's for the person getting the
the gifteds
7 a.m for amir oh my goodness it is
about 10 30 my time oh you guys can see
it right
right down
over here at the bottom right
marvin doing great didn't know where
you're back dude yeah so we uh haven't
haven't really done many twitch streams
lately i might start doing some twitch
gameplay at some point
but i've been doing these uh
live shows this is like the fifth one or
so
tuesday has kind of been our
our night it seems like that one just
works
so we've been doing this live show every
tuesday to talk about
harry potter news hogwarts legacy news
mainly what's going on in games
that sort of thing
sporty yeah
yeah when it was a wee lad
a wee little lad
can't wait to meet nearly headless nick
mr hooded raven
membership did go through on youtube
went through on the bank
[Music]
wait
are you trying to say
keelan trying to say that you um
oh that's weird
oh didn't go through
hmm
yeah i would maybe try to um
that's probably a youtube thing
because i don't think i can uh well what
i could do let me let me look at this
i can pull up on my end and see any new
members
let me see if you're showing up in there
and if not then you should be able to
like
request a refund with your uh
company that's your that's your uh like
however you paid whether it's like
paypal or credit card or something
where is it at here
analytics maybe
so many so many tabs here
okay here we go memberships
um
see your members
yeah it definitely didn't go through on
my end it's not it's not showing up
hey crystal ball thank you for
subscribing to the channel
you're a wizard harry
mathis as well coming in with the
subscription thank you mathis
look at the chalkboard behind your
character in the charms classroom
ace
ace of kings
subscribing as well thank you so much
[Music]
shows up in chat for you to allow gifts
in your channel
so wait demonic one are you saying i
have to do that do i have to enable
something
cause if i need to
i will try to see if i can find it
uh catholic that's a great hold on i
want to get back to that question i
don't want to miss some of these other
comments chalkboard behind your
character in the charms classroom during
the yeah red linus i i have definitely
called that out in some videos before
um
and i wonder if those are all gonna be
in the game
because if they have that many in the
game i mean i think that'd be incredible
oh you do okay i just want to make sure
on demonic one the viewer gets to has to
allow the gift thing gotcha gotcha
gotcha okay
imagine you can walk around in hogwarts
legacy and do a vodka turtle
yeah
minister of magic oh my gosh
[Music]
i
i know people don't like it but i feel
like i feel like that the um
avada kadava is just going to be a
finisher oh somebody was asking about
the music it is uh this
no copyright
youtube page right here so it's celtic
medieval tavr music this one's volume
three relaxation harmony
is the channel right here
but then i want to see uh oh where'd the
question go oh catherine kind of a
personal question after hogwarts legacy
releases what will be next for the
channel sub for hogwarts psychology
really want to see you cover other games
as well so it was next
so
it's
it's open right now catholic so
my
youtube channel
it's i mean i could talk i love talking
about this stuff i love talking about
this stuff
it's um
but i i
i know people probably don't want to get
me to go in this in depth so i'll try to
keep it quick
when i first started i was just like i
want a gaming channel that's really all
i was thinking so i was like you can go
back and look at like my old content it
was just kind of all over the place and
then i sort of started to find this
groove doing animal crossing content my
son and i were playing a ton of animal
crossing at the time to this day my best
two of my top three performing videos
are animal crossing videos even now
and but they were they didn't start off
like that
they had like barely any views at the
beginning so i'm like oh man you know
what i want to cover and then the
hogwarts legacy
first trailer dropped
and i was just like
i gotta make videos on this game because
i'm such a huge harry potter fan i was
like i'm gonna try to make some videos
on this
and then it just kind of took off
i still every now and then we'll get
comments from people like saying dude i
i wish you'd make animal crossing
content again
and it's just like
i'd love to but
my son and i i mean we just don't play
it anymore honestly and then the
hogwarts legacy stuff took off
but that is a question that
i would love i wish i knew the answer
exactly
i'll tell you this catholic er karthik i
think i pronounced your name wrong k.a
karthik my apologies probably not even
saying it right now
i've asked this question a lot on my uh
like youtube community tab because i
really see two paths for the channel
and i'll lay it out to you guys and i'd
love to hear what you all think
i really see two paths one path i see
is
gaming stay with stick with gaming
kind of pull out do a little bit more of
a broad approach to gaming do more
gaming live streams over on youtube
cover more game but even then like
variety is really hard to do on youtube
it's really really tough to have a
successful channel doing variety
so i think i would have to have some
focus even if it's not one game i think
we would have to i would have to really
figure out
do i focus just on games that involve
magic do i focus just on action rpgs do
i focus just on
playstation switch
pc whatever
that would be one path figuring out a
gaming route
the other route
i see is the route of
harry potter
and instead of just covering
covering like the harry potter phantom
so
everything from new tv there's rumor of
tv shows
all the other harry potter video games
so
hogwarts mystery um
oh what's the one that everybody's
waiting to come out in the us um
magic awakened
potential hogwarts legacy sequels if
they ever announce an mmo
um
any future fantastic beasts movies harry
potter retrospectives
think like um
super carlin brothers movie flame
if you've seen any of their videos
a little bit of harry potter theory
mixed in there
and then with all sort of like the video
like always kind of coming back to if
there's ever any video game set in the
wizarding world coming back to that
so that's sort of like those are the
ideas bouncing around right now i've
also thought about making a completely
separate channel calling it retro potter
and that being like the the dedicated
harry potter channel obviously hogwarts
legacy stuff would all stay i'll stay
here but
i could really talk about that question
a long time because i'm i'm trying to
figure it out myself i'm already
thinking about that too i i feel like
it also depends on what the future of
hogwarts legacy holds right because you
look at like the souls games and their
channels built around
they literally only cover the souls
games
and that's it
that's it they only cover the souls
games so depending on the success
success of hogwarts legacy how well it
does how big it is
um the possibility of sequels and that
sort of thing
that's another part of it too so a
really long answer
but yeah i do want to cover more games
i'm actually working on a god of war
video
right now i'm working on a god of war um
like some of my favorite bosses of god
of war is the video so i'm gonna do some
like sort of testing some experimenting
on the channel
in the next few months as we're still
putting out hogwarts legacy content
[Music]
and then the other thing i can't figure
out is um
the let's plays
because a lot of people here in the chat
love the let's plays
the reality is the let's plays like
they actually like
when i first started doing them i don't
think it's this way anymore but when i
first started doing them i would like
lose i would see i would lose
subscribers i can go in on the video and
i could see how many people subscribe on
a video i would lose subscribers on the
let's place i'm like this is so weird
youtube right now it's so like
uh it's so driven by like the the niche
and so i think the audience for let's
plays is just a little bit different
from the more like general news audience
so i actually have a separate let's play
channel now but i'm still posting the
hogwarts the harry potter ones here on
the main channel but yeah it's a big
question
it's a big question i'd love to see your
all's feedback though
all right so i'm gonna get caught up on
the
comments here
yeah keelan you should be able to figure
out
you definitely need to be able to get
your money back keelan for sure
because i don't know why i'm i wish i
was more experienced on youtube
memberships and that sort of thing
i know i i joined expecto go's channel
like a week or so ago and it just
like it went through right away
if you did um if you did it with a
credit card i mean you like that would
be
credit card companies are pretty good
about that you could just go and dispute
the charge and say this this didn't go
through
[Music]
all right let's get caught up with the
comments here
okay lords of the fallen will it be an
elder ring to your souls game oh
i haven't read that much into lords of
the fallen
marvin
is it looking pretty uh looking pretty
slick
only in pc we should be able to torture
dennis umbridge i don't think albert is
going to be in this game maybe an
ancestor of them bridge
tavern champ yeah i love this music
people keep asking about the music
here it is
this right here
celtic medieval and they have a
they have a lot of them i just have to
be careful for the live stream i have to
make sure it's like
copyright free so this one's relaxation
harmony here
celtic medieval tavr music
[Music]
they need to contact google play yeah
that's exactly what i would do stargazer
google and youtube play
either that or a refund for sure wonder
who the caretaker is shadowing you know
what it's crazy about that is i thought
hey scott thank you for subbing to the
channel
in my mind i always like think the
caretaker is a squib
you're a wizard
but that doesn't have to be the case you
know that was just
in the situation of phil's
herodl thank you for subscribing to the
channel as well
[Music]
amore poet i guess that only pops up if
you um
get a gifted membership i don't know
[Music]
finisher yes maybe we could choose to
kill through choices that's a
possibility too
[Music]
nico oh my gosh you
dude that is a d i did not realize you'd
been around that long nico
honestly those first luigi's mansion
videos
oh my gosh dude
one of the things that people say about
youtubers first starting out is that
they always think their videos are
better than they are
and
the majority of my videos i agree but
dude i put so much editing into some of
those first luigi's mansion videos
i go back and watch them i was like
i think this was pretty funny
i'm like i think this is pretty funny
why didn't this get more views
i even put my head in the thumbnail like
on
luigi as he's like holding the vacuum
yeah they didn't do well
so go back and watch them guys let me
know what you think
[Music]
dude nico i did not realize you had been
here since some of those videos
shadow guys struggling to stay awake hey
good night shadow appreciate you hanging
out
can't believe you guys stay up so late
i'm a night owl too though i really am
maybe we could do role-playing games
yeah see
we fit with the tagline to let me games
stories to tell right right right and
then another option is i also have an
interest in doing
sort of like a cross between video game
retrospectives
i don't really know the right name for
it i feel like it would be closest to
retrospectives but more with like a
character focus so like a character
retrospective on
some of my favorite video game
characters
from the attic think action adventure
rpgs be best path in fact this would be
considering yourself to be honest
nice yeah it's like
you just it's it's just so hard
to be
brought i mean it's so hard to cover a
broad range of topics on youtube
especially if you're like i am from the
attic and you're like a one-man show
it's like it's not like i have a team to
support me you know don't have a team i
also work another full-time job
have a wife have kids
um
and then also like
as much as i love covering hogwarts
legacy i think i want to bring i'd like
to break out of the mold of being a news
centric channel
because news content is so hard to do on
youtube guys because it's it's fleeting
you know
it's only relevant for
in fact if you go and look
you can look at my you can go and look
at this on my channel right now you can
sort by like most views
the videos that tend to do the best
are the ones that have what i call like
the most evergreen potential so like
once hogwarts legacy finally launches
the vast majority
this is just the reality hey thank you
for subscribing that is a really long
name park ranger thank you for
subscribing to the channel but yeah once
hogwarts honestly comes out all these
hogwarts legacy news videos that are
doing great for us right now
they're out the door they're gonna be
going they're gonna get like zero views
whereas like
the uh one of my most probably the video
that i'm most proud of on my channel is
the complete history of harry potter
video games which is on track to be my
it's not the highest viewed video yet
but it's on track to be
that took so much time but it's it's an
evergreen type of video
because that will be relevant even after
hogwarts legacy comes out
that'll be relevant many years from now
when people want to go back and like
check out kind of the history got a war
crowd similar to hogwarts
yeah harry potter content could be
limiting
that is that is definitely another uh
thing to consider
yeah i'm working on a god of war video
we'll see how that one goes
fantasy game yeah see that's what i'm i
one of my ideas was like if i just
started covering video games that have
like the loose thread that ties it all
together would be magic
any game that has like some sort of
magic did i pronounce it lunum i don't
even remember i go i switch between
niche and niche
i actually switch between it because
it's i think i think grammatically i
think both are actually correct
i always like to say niche but i think
most people
in the us say niche
[Music]
youtube algorithm it's hard to get out
of what you usually make content about
yeah that that is
that's true hannah
that is true
because what what essentially happens is
like like when i put out this god of war
video
i know it's not gonna do like my
hogwarts legacy videos do it the at the
beginning
because that's just not how because it's
going to show that video
because it's like oh dude all these
hogwarts legacy fans it's going to show
you get a lot of people that video but
then if they're not also interested in
god of war they're not going to click so
that sends a signal to youtube it's like
oh their subscribers aren't clicking now
that video can still have success but
it's more of like a long tail approach
takes a lot longer
which back to the animal crossing thing
remember how i said the animal crossing
thing did nothing at the beginning dude
it's crazy you go in my youtube
analytics on animal crossing and it's
like
the video that is number one on my
channel right now
top 10 secrets of animal crossing
horizon the first like three four months
this video is like it's almost like a
flat line i mean i'm talking like
10 videos or 10 videos 10 views 100
views 300 views
800 views a thousand views oh now we're
3000 views 4 000 views and then just out
of nowhere it's just like
it just takes off
it's like
the algorithm finally found the people
that wanted that video
and boom it just
it was the most amazing thing i've ever
seen like
in all the all the videos that i've
covered on my channel i've never had one
except for the hairy the complete
history of harry potter games i had a
pretty good feeling that that one was
going to do well
i didn't necessarily know it was going
to take off so quickly though
jamie triwizard tournament would be
awesome in this game i mean try wizard
tournament is like it's tail it's a
perfect video game um
like mechanic
unfortunately the timing
with hogwarts psychosis doesn't work out
because they um they would have already
like banned the triwizard tournament now
according to canon we do know that they
tried to bring it back a couple of times
so if it were to appear in hogwarts
legacy they would have to do it under
the guise of like hey we're trying to
bring back the tournament
but i don't it just feels too big for me
maybe it's maybe like
maybe in a sequel
i don't think they'll do it for this
game though
dustin any ideas on being able to use
imperius
i i've talked about that in a couple
videos dustin i think i think imperio
has the most
gameplay utility for sure
and now that we've got two unforgivables
confirmed i think we could pretty much
take it to the bank that um
that the imperial is going to be in
there too
it definitely yeah it definitely seems
like the most spammable it's not one
that you it doesn't have so many other
things tied to it like with crucio you
have to mean it harry potter couldn't
even cast it on bellatrix because even
though he was like in a rage against her
he
didn't fully
have that hatred
to be able to to get it to work
effectively
imperial though deathly hallows he's
like
imperial on the goblins like it was
nothing
hey luke thank you for subscribing to
the channel let's plays usually live in
real time that's a good point tom that's
a good point they're not
traditionally they are not and and let's
plays like that's
that is one of the hardest things to get
traction on in youtube because it's just
like it's just been done so many times
it's been done so many times and
they're videos that
it's a it's a commitment like it is a
long time commitment to sit down and
watch somebody play through a whole game
but yeah i feel like the live streams
might be an interesting way
i'm still kind of undecided on whenever
i start streaming games again if i want
to do it on twitch or do it on youtube i
mean clearly youtube is the home of my
live the live weekly show
that that is going to be like a staple i
hope even after hogwarts and we could
talk about
all other sorts of games and uh
other harry potter stuff
so if i did it on twitch then i would
bring them i would
if i did the
gameplay live streams on twitch what i
would probably do is
then take that vod and post to us the
separate youtube channel that i have
just for let's plays
however if i keep everything on youtube
i do kind of like having this because
youtube treats live streams differently
now
so they would like after this live
stream ends it'll be available for
people to go back and watch
but it doesn't necessarily like
count against me in the algorithm if
that makes sense because the algorithm
sees oh
this is a live video this is a much more
this is a long form content this is not
the same
type of video that retro just posted
today
that was like a 20 minute video
breakdown of the latest trailer
[Music]
but yeah that's a really good point tom
like in the future if i
i'm finishing up the pro
to nathan's next question there i'm the
prisoner of azkaban let's plays are
pretty much done
there's one more thing that i'm waiting
on
um
that i can't
talk about much yet but um
there might be something a little
special that goes with that one but that
one's gonna be
there might be one more after that but i
have beaten the game now i'm just trying
to decide if i want to do a final one to
like wrap up and get all the
collectibles
but i wanted to keep all those the same
so at least if people watch the previous
let's plays that i've done it's all the
exact same kind of format but then after
that
i'm really curious to hear what you guys
say because i want to play through
um i have chamber of secrets on pc that
i want to play through
i'm gonna do goblet of fire i i am gonna
do the console version of gobble to fire
[Music]
all right i'm gonna start rolling
through these comments because i'm
i'm just getting way behind
combined let's plays and news like run
through the game killing stuff and in
today's harry potter news oh yeah that's
an idea rain and thunder
cam what is your favorite harry potter
book and movie
book is deathly hallows
movie
depends on the day you ask me
i would probably say prisoner of azkaban
right now
rossi maybe focus on rpg yeah yeah
that's an idea too
there's a vampire in the game hey white
wolf welcome back
you think there's a vampire in the game
it'll be crazy
oh the trailer for that just came out
during gamescom nice
oh yeah i haven't i'll have to check
that one out
wonder if kettleberry will be the beast
professor
i think this should be long before
i actually don't know about kettleberry
should be long before kettleberry though
i believe
hey d jane thanks for hanging out good
night
kela wish that jumanji like jumanji ever
get taken into the world i live my life
as a wizard
mr bust welcome back night out for life
yeah literally night i woke up from a
nap a couple hours ago
dude if i didn't have to work keep like
because my my job the job that i'm in
now i do have some flexibility but we
have like a lot of i could work from
home some days and like i could even
work right after we hop on
i finish this live stream i could hop on
and do some work now
um
but
i do have to keep some hours that are
close to everyone else
for meetings and all that sort of thing
all sorts all those sorts of things
first person al mode dogwoods legacy
that would be insane
super art that is exactly it i get my
best work done at night
because my my kids are asleep
and then my wife usually goes to bed
pretty early so i don't i don't feel
like i'm neglecting or not spending time
with her she goes to bed early and so
it's like that's when i my light bulb
comes on and i'm
i can get my most work done whenever i
get up early and try to get work done
it's like i always feel like there's
this ticking clock
and there should be that same ticking
clock at night
but it's like at night it's like yeah i
could just push back my bedtime a little
bit not what you should do guys not what
you should do
it's not healthy
but no i do i try to get at least seven
hours every night but eight is really my
goal
star geezer a stargazer thank you for
all the support tonight really really do
appreciate it
from the attic think you strike a good
balance between news and opinions feel
like opinions stand the test of time
yeah yeah if you do a little bit more uh
things that are kind of more evergreen
in nature 302 likes yo let's go
online quidditch matches that would be
cool but
quidditch is not gonna be playable guys
you heard it here first
well you heard it in my video a month or
so ago
it is going to be in the game like
quidditch will be in the game but it's
it's just not going to be playable
hogwarts like is setting up a trilogy
hoping that completing the story doesn't
take 12 years yeah i hope not and and
the fact that
this is avalanche first game of this
type i feel like a sequel would take
much less time because they're going to
have they're going to have everything i
mean all the assets are gonna be ready
to go
the castle i mean just think how long it
would take it took them to build
everything the castle's gonna be ready
to go
yeah
yeah evergreen content super that's
right but like i can't
also sprinkling in the new stuff too at
least until the hogwarts legacy
news cycle is is all
finished and done but that's you know
that's still gonna be a while
[Music]
yeah the algorithm is fascinating it
really is
[Music]
i mean i've learned that the algorithm
is really all about people
it's all about people optimize for
people not the algorithm
favorite harry potter game that i've
played
chamber of secrets on gamecube
that's the one i have the most fond
memories of yeah
nico you think the hatred for egad
deserves a few thousand views i thought
it was some top-notch editing there i
really did
dylan have you noticed in the clip where
a wizard is flying a broom through the
forest it looks like they're set on a
strict path instead of being able to
travel openly throughout the forest
you're right it does kind of look like
that
you're definitely right
i've always known that in my mind but i
don't think i've ever thought about what
that
could possibly mean until that right
there
so like is it on rails somewhat now is
it then it's like was it just for that
that little mission that we're on is it
just for that specific section could we
hop off the broom right there because i
think
i think the forest is going to be fairly
explorable i really do
yeah i mean on the sequel jamie they've
said
they they
they have said if the game is supported
that they want to do more
in the world they just they straight
upset it
favorite hp movie why why was it
prisoner azkaban
[Music]
i don't know i just feel like
first of all they all have they all have
problems
they all have big problems i think my
issues with
my issues with five it's honestly like i
hate to say this but it's just like
process of elimination
it's process of elimination one in two i
really like one and two they're the most
book accurate
but
as movies
they weren't as entertaining i feel like
four five six and both sevens
i there are parts of them and i
absolutely love and then parts of them
that i just find so frustrating
so it just like kind of by process of
elimination like prisoner of azkaban is
the one that i have the least
big problems with
talking about azkaban canon says to date
serious black is the only individual
known to escape azkaban without any
outside help note without help
[Music]
breaking sebastian out of azkaban would
be incredible
two and a half hours i know these
streams fly by and i've been standing
this whole time
you guys it's it's hard to tell like on
the video probably but yeah i met i'm at
my standing i've got my desk in a
standing position right now so
i've been uh moving the knees this whole
time
harry potter movie instagram might be a
hogwarts legacy announcement harry
potter movie instagram
are they talking about the um
the back to hogwarts thing
is that like a fan account or what
harry potter movie
instagram
harry potter film maybe
[Music]
oh yeah i'm so glad you brought this up
oh my gosh do i really like to sign into
instagram
uh fine
i hardly ever use instagram guys i'm on
there but
feel free to follow me but i i don't
post a lot at all
i do not post a lot there
i'm retrorecording to her over there
though as well
all right here we go
ah come back
what do you guys think
i think somebody on twitter nailed it
somebody said like
oh you know what i just realized
somebody i don't think it's all relating
to hogwarts legacy this one is clearly
relating to that harry potter
magic wand cast or whatever
this one is probably for hogwarts legacy
right here and then this one i have no
idea i don't think they're all for
hogwarts legacy
i think some people saw it probably
thought
does this mean
multiplayer
companions no i don't think they're all
relating to here's what the
post says can you guess what our
announcements might be keep an eye on
the wizarding world youtube channel to
find out on september 1st
[Music]
hey dubstep thanks for stopping by and
hanging out have a good one
harry potter console games are so rare
are they actually rare now
i bought um
for my live stream i had to go i didn't
have own a copy of prisoner of azkaban
so i went on ebay and bought a gamecube
copy for like i don't know 20 bucks or
so
jamie thanks for hanging out dude have a
good night appreciate you stopping by
nathan can't wait to see the end of
prisoner of azkaban yeah yeah keep an
eye out keep an eye out
oh my gosh i get so behind on comments
krusty if they'll add wellness magic
somebody asked me that was that you
somebody asked me that on a
youtube video today
i don't think so because it's like so
it's supposed to be so advanced right
but our our character has this sort of
special ancient magic ability so maybe
maybe we will j rossi dude thank you for
hanging out have a good night
wubby i definitely think they want to
make a sequel so i think if the game
does well in terms of sales
i think we'll get one
finishing goblet tonight starting order
tomorrow nice let's go hope they had a
trailer at least once a month before the
release fog were so i could keep it
exciting
yes and no tom i definitely want him to
keep up
the promo i don't know about a trailer
every month because i don't want them to
reveal
here's what i want to see i want to see
gameplay
show me a gameplay breakdown and that's
all that's all i need personally i don't
want them to reveal too much about the
story i want us to be just like
completely shocked by the story
so
i feel like the lead up to red dead man
rockstar does such a good job with like
those little trailers that they would
release
tired of all the dark arts content yes
we do amore i agree we need to see
everybody loves the dark art stuff
they do
but i agree we need to see some of the
other stuff how about unexpected
patronum
how about an expecto patronum
[Music]
yeah that's right shadowing i think so
goblins do that's right dustin and we
see the goblin using wandless magic
from the edit what i think crazy about
content from my experience videos on
games from the past
and games from the future work really
well if it's something recent you need
to be yeah either super fast or already
like a huge established creator you know
you're a wizard you already have that
big established fan base who's
interested in it yeah james thank you so
much for subscribing james
yeah no problem dylan that's what this
is for man i love these live streams
yeah nico i saw those and actually
that's why i pulled up the website here
i wanted to make sure
everybody saw these new editions so this
is not i know this is not the wallpaper
you guys were talking about but
the these are some new uh
screenshots that they added
i mean is this fiendfire
is this fiend fire
that is a incredibly roaring fire right
there and then you got the spider right
here
this one shot from the trailer yeah this
one is like they just like dropped that
in like
yeah this is not from the
it's not from the trailer at all we're
just dropping this new
just dropping this new shot
but these are both from the trailer
same for that one right there
[Music]
and fury look looking creepy
it looking creepy
[Music]
three is great five is two four could
have been better if they follow the book
more
yeah four four i feel like is the one
people hate on the most i give it a
little bit more of a pass than a lot of
people simply because they
the
scene that they needed to nail the most
they nailed it the graveyard scene
[Music]
incredible
the third task
dropped the ball big time the graveyard
scene though
the climax of the movie
amazing
amazing but yeah everything else people
were very
very disappointed in how they handled a
lot of that
five my biggest problem with five as
great as the effects are in the
voldemort dumbledore battle
and this is this is the little thing if
i rewatched it now i would probably like
five better i honestly would but in the
theater what disappointed me so much
is that
dumbledore in the duel
he he's like it's like he's struggling
it's like he's like
he's like barely hanging on
but the image you get when you read in
the book
dumbledore is just so chill
he's so he's just like
he makes it look easy
but yet
in five in the movie dumbledore looks
like this old man where you're really
like oh my gosh
he's like doing everything he can to
hang on dude no
that's not how it was he strolls in
there casually and is like
tom what are you doing here tom should
not have come here tonight tom
she's like
here's this giant orb of water
just like that
the wand movements they're supposed to
be smooth and
not like oh i'm struggling i i'm trying
to hold this
oh
like i said if i it's it's a little
thing if i watch it now i'll probably be
fine
oh yeah did you put your name into the
goblet of
fire forever be remembered jordan have a
good night jordan thank you for hanging
out
i am gryffindor james
yeah amore i feel like patronus has to
be in
because we've gotten another
confirmation that the mentors are in
with the the new boxer
thinking of firestorm is there
there a spell called firestorm
ravenclaw friend
i mean we don't know about the ravenclaw
friend do we do you have a theory
ned
yo what's up james
half blood prince movie if they included
the scenes
of bob ogden at the house of gaunt
oh man
yeah six
that's probably the movie i remember the
least
why i don't know
i hate five is the worst movie
[Music]
windows in the castle they're not
see-through uh
which ones you talking about james from
the um
[Music]
are you talking
[Music]
about hold on hold on hold on
[Music]
where do i have that saved i know i have
it saved somewhere because i just used
it in a video
you're talking about the uh the stained
glass one
oh this one right here
is this the one
[Music]
gabriel yeah there was a lot they could
have added
are you talking about the are you
talking about the final
you talking about dumbledore voldemort
or harry voldemore in book seven or
movie seven
that was my biggest problem with movie
seven
[Music]
they ruined the final fight
harry v voldemort they ruined it
they have them like like wrestling and
grabbing each other's face i'm just like
on the the close-up shot it's like it's
just so cringe
oh it's just so cringe
and it wasn't in that it was supposed to
be in the great hall
with everybody around
oh
david yates
it angers me so much okay sorry
okay deep breath
oh the spell that's right yeah the spell
that dumbledore uses in the cave
yes yes yes
[Music]
you're a wizard harry
marky thank you for subscribing to the
channel
yep that too curtis
that too curtis
oh i'm gonna mispronounce that terribly
selvat
phyllis stayless thank you so much for
subscribing to the channel
after reading the books i can't watch
the films and like them as much as what
i used to
yeah i just like i have to separate them
in my mind i do
i have to separate them i appreciate the
films for what they are and for helping
to
i mean really help take it even i mean
it was already kind of mainstream but
the films really helped take it
big time mainstream right
and the first two are pretty freaking
accurate
they're pretty act like the first two
did such a good job of setting the stage
like i i honestly like i don't know
maybe like ramp up the action a bit in
the first two but i
i don't know what more they could have
done in the first two really because
you're dealing with this the child
actors were really young at that time so
the acting's not going to be as good
that's just part of it
kevin that is a theory
that i
thought up
as we were talking in chat last week
that would be incredible
just insane we have that shot in the in
the most recent trailer where the troll
is attacking the lone and furious
the single of inferior is in furious
i got to make sure to use that somebody
call me on it
in the comments today
so gotta make sure of that
but um
the the troll attacks the inferiors so
either
either there's just like an all-out
brawl and the troll just doesn't care
that's option one option two the troll
is under imperio by us
option three
we're playing as evil and we created
them furious
oh my gosh
like why would the troll be attacking
the inferiors
trio seeing gildaway lockhart at st
mungo's after arthur's attack meeting
devil's parents there shame it's all cut
from the movie
yeah
that's true
that too yup
i do feathers i do and the fact that
i wonder if it's going to be all very on
the nose like if poppy will be
somehow relate to helga
if natsai will somehow relate to
gryffindor
oh james says look at the ravenclaw room
versus gryffindor room windows
gryffindor you see the castle
ravenclaw's just wait ah you're talking
about the common room shots
gotcha
yeah chris columbus did a great job
no peeves that yeah that's the one thing
that they had to cut
that that's the one like book thing
that they didn't weren't able to fit in
the first two movies and then didn't fit
in any of the movies
i agree on yates i just wasn't i wasn't
a fan of yates i like the idea of
switching up and keeping it fresh with
directors and honestly like i feel like
yates has not been great for
fantastic beasts either
those have been a big a big
i don't know the first one was pretty
good
but i still don't feel like it was
[Music]
i don't know i don't know where i'd rank
them all
might be a video topic right there
[Music]
poppy's surname is really lestrange
[Music]
wait what
[Music]
where does where is that one coming from
demonic one i have missed that
you're a wizard it's poppy sweeting
right in the trailer
come on thank you for subscribing
hope the slytherin windows show the lake
not just wizard
mohawk rage
thank you for subscribing as well
[Music]
you're a wizard harry
normak lee normak thank you for
subscribing as well
troll can also just be on our side
remember in prison of azkaban natural
[Music]
i do remember that ezra thanks to the
prisoner of azkaban video game
i had completely forgotten that that was
canon i actually made fun of it in the
title of that let's play so i was like
what is this the games having them
employ trolls to guard the uh
what and then somebody pointed out this
is actually canon they they gave me the
passage and i was like
i completely forgot about that
[Music]
troll can oh i already read that one
crazy not sure what happened to your uh
comment crazy phoenix sorry it um
if it detected it as a link or is this
family-friendly stream so
you could try to try to submit it again
oh is this a thing you've got going with
james
with uh
poppy
oh you deleted oh okay gotcha
that's funny
yeah james lots of uh lots of astrology
sun and moon
lots of interesting symbols for sure
all right man we are we are officially
over the three hour mark guys
we are officially over the three hour
mark yeah crazy phoenix the behind thing
that's
i tried to turn down the latency youtube
has a couple latency options that's just
the nature of a live stream
unfortunately it kind of runs a little
bit behind the chat so that's why it
takes me sometimes a couple minutes or
so to catch up to everything
oh
that's right you talking bad about poppy
oh i'll have to remember that
i'll have to remember that
wonder if you can pick your patronus we
don't know yet
we do not know yet
maybe we'll get something back to
hogwarts about it i don't know we shall
see
guys it has been over three hours it is
11 almost 11 30 my time i got work
tomorrow so i think we're gonna go ahead
and wrap it up there tonight
but um thank you guys so much for
hanging out man these are always an
absolute blast
an absolute blast we covered a lot of
ground tonight covered a lot of topics
so i hope you all have a fantastic rest
of your week we will have at least one
more video dropping this week
obviously you know we gotta have a video
going up about whatever is announced at
the back to hogwarts day
hopefully it's something big hopefully
something big i may even you know what i
might try and live stream it
i might try and live stream it i can't
commit to that for sure because it's
during the day so i'll have to check my
work schedule
see if i can
work from home that day and then get
enough work done before and after
but yeah i would love to live stream it
be fun
marvin yay good to see you too marvin
thanks for stopping by man
king says wait what are we waiting for
i don't know king what are you waiting
for
what are you waiting for king you mean
the the back to hogwarts day
are you talking about the uh sometimes
there's a little delay between chat and
uh youtube we were talking about that
too
but the back to hogwarts stuff is on
september 1st 1 20 eastern time
[Music]
oh yeah yeah yeah so it's um
see i may have already closed it out
here
right here chandler would confirm
they'll be part of uh back to hogwarts
so september 1st
at 1 20 there's uh 1 20 eastern time
there's going to be a video going up all
the details are here
on the official actually what youtube
channel is it
it is the
youtube.com
c wizarding world it's the official
wizarding world youtube
yep
good night guys yeah thank you all so
much for hanging out kathy thank you for
stopping by as well feathers as well
ryan nico dude nico i think nico's here
the whole time
and ryan
ryan's name has been in here i think
this whole time as well
yeah congrats to all those with the
gifted thanks everybody who showed
support of the stream which
please guys never ever ever feel
obligated to donate to some to uh well
subscribe yes go ahead subscribing's
free
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
no charge at all but never feel
obligated at all man um
like take care of yourself
take care of yourself and everything
everything you got to do first if you if
you want to show support of the channel
there are so many ways to support the
channel that do not involve
money at all share the videos like the
videos comment on the videos all those
help out big time big time
um but yeah man that's gonna be it for
me tonight hope you all have a fantastic
rest of your week i'll be over on
twitter tweeting out about hogwarts
legacy pre-order stuff any any of the
big news i'll be posting about as well
and you could definitely expect at least
one more video this week i'll let you
know on twitter if we can end up doing a
live stream on uh back to hogwarts day
we'll see so uh thank you so much for
watching everybody have a fantastic rest
of your
evening morning
depending on where you are right
all right guys thanks so much have a
good one
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]